Hello
everyone.
Confused now.
Oh.
I'm so tired.
I'm okay.
I just merely have failed another nap.
Gotcha.
like guys but i'm okay i'm i'm so healthy
i give me a sec whoops okay uh good morning everyone oh shit
6 p.m sorry good out good evening everyone give me a second
i'm okay i guess you You think I'm okay?
Give me a sec.
Let me fix this real quick.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Give me a walk, walk, walk, walk.
All right.
I have my little Dairy Queen ice cream that I've kept in my
freezer for a month, so it should be fine.
Did you know Dairy Queen has this new thing where where you
can get like miniature ice cream cakes but they're like
called ice cream cupcakes and it's basically like an ice
cream cake but it's like a smaller version and that's why
it's called a cupcake that's why that's why it's called and
so it has like the little fudge, the fudge part that makes
all the Dairy Queen ice cream so good.
And it's like the little fudge thing with the little fudge
in the middle.
Like the chocolate and the little fudge fudge in the middle
and the vanilla.
Oh, I love ice cream.
He's circling me.
This will help me.
I okay I'm okay
I just failed the nap Gotcha I was trying to be so
productive today I was like Oh I woke up I was like don't
worry I'm gonna finish do my schedule Finish my schedule And
then Clean my apartment and then uh and then we streamed
that and then clean it before dad comes back tonight by the
way i was like don't worry i got this i woke up at like i
woke up at 12 p.m and i was just like i got this i'm gonna
get up clean my do my schedule and then clean my apartment
and it was 2 p.m and i was I and I was like oh but before I
do all of that I should get some food because I'm so hungry
I should take a shower too and and then get some food and I
was like well I can't work and then my food arrived and I
was like well I can't work while like I'm hungry so I should
eat my food first and I was like um yum yum yum and I was
like well I have to watch something while I'm eating my food
so I was like um yum yum yum and And then I finished eating,
and I was like, in the middle of my, uh, in the middle of
my, by the way, I've, I never finished Modern Family.
I remember when Modern Family was still on.
So I've been, uh, just recently started watching Modern
Family again from all the way from the beginning.
But I remember I stopped that season three, uh, when,
because I would, I didn't watch the stream.
Like, I didn't, it was on streaming service.
So I actually just watched it whenever it was on TV.
So I think it was like around season three when I stopped
watching it.
So I was like, oh, I gotta start all the way from the
beginning.
eating so I shouldn't I there's no way I should like just
stop in the middle of the episode I should watch it all the
way to the end and then I did that and then and I was like
well now that I'm done eating um I need to relax a little
bit before I go back to work mode and then I was like all
right all right oh now that I'm done done relaxing it's now
like 3 p.m.
and I was just like well
and then I'll get back into like figuring out my schedule
and then it was like uh and then it was like 4 p.m.
and then I was just like well all right let me go see what
to do on my schedule and I put everything compile everything
in my schedule and then I was like whoa good job dokey I
still have an hour and 30 minutes left till my stream all
right let me put some stuff in the uh before I everything in
Photoshop together, let me just lie down in bed for a little
bit because I did such a good job putting everything
together in my Google calendar.
Let me just lie down in my bed for a little bit to
congratulate myself on a job well done.
And I lied on the bed and I realized it was 5 p.m.
And I was like, well, maybe I'll take a small nap and then
I'll clean up.
And I put everything on the schedule on stream.
And then I guess fuck dad.
Because I'm not going to clean my apartment.
And it went out.
Wake up.
So now we're here.
You're getting hot fire.
It's just, fuck him, I guess.
So, no, no, I completed my schedule.
I just didn't put it.
I just didn't put it in Photoshop.
I'm gonna put, I'm gonna put stuff in front.
Let me put stuff on Photoshop real quick.
Please go back to sleep so I can make back my lost betting
money.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's one thing.
One thing, though.
That I know I will not fuck up on.
I'll be on time.
And it's just being plus one on that leaderboard.
That's right.
I still have one goal in mind.
goal on hand and that's making it to the leaderboard that's
still on the board that's the most important thing in my
list it's just that i just have to be on time for the
leaderboard all else fails at least i'm plus one stream on
the board i'll show you guys my schedule for those who are
like um or like what did you do yes i did and here it is i
just put it on photoshop right now so here long you see that
long arm recording all right we're finally on saturday we're
gonna catch up we're gonna finally catch up on the the
birthday gifts from a month ago and a bomber bed uh brahma
bird so members karaoke tomorrow all right let me actually
put everything together at least i can tweet this out it's
in the middle of my stream give me a sec guys i told you i
put everything on the calendar and i was like good job jokey
Good job, Doki.
You did a great job.
It's 10 plus minute bedtime.
You get recess, Doki.
Yippee!
Reset!
Wow.
Good job, little Doki.
As teacher, Doki, I'm going to grant you a little recess
time.
Yippee!
I'm my own boss.
Look at that.
The benefits of being my own boss.
I get to give myself recess time.
And then I lost the nap.
Got to do.
All right.
Give me a sec, guys.
Let me...
I actually was like, what did I do with my time?
I like woke up and I was like, what did I do with my time?
I thought I had so much time.
And that was the whole reason why I started at six.
I was like, I need to give myself extra time so I can make
sure I clean my apartment.
I have enough time to clean my apartment and also make my
schedule.
And I was like, where did all the time go?
I thought I had enough.
How did I not get anything done other than doing my
schedule, of course?
How did I just need to post it?
not get anything done i don't understand i thought i had so
much time i where did it all go i actually was like looking
back and i was like where did it all go i i don't i don't
understand what was i doing all that time I don't understand
I was looking at my history and my like um chrome history
just to be like what was I looking at what was I looking at
to have to let this happen and it was just it was just all
gone it's so fast everything went by so fast I still don't
know how all that I don't remember I legitimately don't
remember oh I okay okay this is where I started doom
scrolling I can see all the Twitter links here so that's I
was just like okay all right I can see all the Twitter links
at this time so I know I was doom scrolling there but What
happened after?
What happened?
At six hours.
What happened to six hours?
I'll never know.
I guess I'll never know.
I guess it is truly a mystery.
All right, guys, let me...
Let me put it on my schedule.
together first and then i don't want to do a stream okay let
me see um
i'm gonna get my texting up where's this um oh this was my
little oh my god this was like my little fucking resolution
my new year's
We've only done one thing from my New Year's resolution.
I just looked at it all.
It's just like, no, we got video upload to 100 million.
I'm sorry, 100 million.
That would be crazy.
We didn't get video to a million views, though.
You know what?
We got one thing off of that.
I call that a success.
I'm, I call that.
success we did it guys all right um give me give me a just
finishing schedule and then we game just let me finish my
schedule first guys and then we'll we'll do stuff i just
need a i just need to make sure i couldn't delay the stream
you know why we couldn't delay the stream.
Alright, it is 23.
It's Juge's birthday today.
You couldn't be here, so I'm overdrafting the super for him
to get a birthday.
Oh my god!
Happy birthday, Juge.
If you're watching the fun, thank you for super chat,
Maddie.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday, Juge.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Juge.
to you yeah oh shit my ice cream oh my arm is filled with
cream and and vanilla now now all right give me sorry i i
have a birthday birthday to you yeah sorry my arm landed on
the top of the ice cream um because it i put it right under
my hand and i was like boom all right give me a sec let me
wash my arm real quick i'll be right back guys i'll be right
back everybody back
i'm back got my ice cream sorted out all right give me a sec
whoop all right let me finish up my schedule guys uh what am
i saying i want to say something i've got oh no the dementia
is hitting down oh no it'll look like i have dementia too i
look like a a dementia patient oh granny it's not it's not
20 26 no more granny it's stop thinking you're streaming
right now there's no You're just in a home, sitting in bed,
talking to your TV.
I've finished putting all the information here.
all right i was gonna say what was i gonna say okay oh yeah
so kodaman kodaman i don't know anything about this game the
only reason i'm playing it was i saw somebody on twitter be
like toky birds in this game and i was like oh shit what
that's it that's really it i just saw someone I don't know
if I was stalking If I was like stalking myself And then I
saw someone I was like, don't give me a drink of this game
On a random tweet and I was like, oh shit Well, I don't
call, I guess I'll play it There's like a There's like a
little Hidden Easter egg For like, there's like basically
Hidden Easter eggs of YouTubers Like parodies of YouTubers
or something And like Um like apparently um so uh one of the
cards is a parody of me and so i wanted to that's why i was
like oh i guess i should check it out now that's how they
get you and they're like damn that's how they get to free
publicity they struck my ego and it's like oh shit don't
even need to pay me to play your game i'm just like i'm in
that game fuck guess i have to play it now They got me know
how to get me And they know They play to my ego It's just
that easy Yeah I'm just that easy guys It's free turkey
tizing I fell for it I fell for it Alright let's see I mean
the reviews seem good i legitimately have no idea what this
game is about i just know i'm it i just know there's a
random like easter egg with me in it so i legitimately
that's all i'm i'm aiming for
check the tags oh no
i did not check the tags but what oh okay no there's that's
not true because That can't be right.
That can't be right, guys.
Do you know why I know that can't be right?
Because my Steam account has some illustrations for the
trading cards.
Depict characters in revealing clothing, tight clothing, and
our sexual poses.
Well, full nudity, nipples, or genitals.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say that can't be right.
Because my account, my account has it so it doesn't show me
R18.
stuff so so no hentai will show up on my steam on my steam
catalog when i'm browsing steam so that's why i know it
can't be right if i see it i know it's safe i'm on safe for
work mode guys this is all safe for work quick guys i still
need to finish my schedule at 5 p.m is members karaoke
because i want to have a little bit a variety um for this
week take a little breather from pal world bum bum bum okay
and then let's see armor core will be a long day uh and then
we have peak with the sloppy sisters all right and that and
then bomber bird plus catching up on birthday gifts we're
finally gonna look through all the birthday gifts we got
last year and also the bomber bird the game that uh the game
that you guys made for me that i've been trying meaning to
check out for a while and i've been so caught up with so
many things but now i'll be able to find look at look at it
no a lot of hard work was put on to it too so I'm super
excited okay let me make sure I got the time uh the time
zones correctly too time conversion correctly that is my
biggest weakness by the way so fucking bad with with time
zones and converting time stuff all right all right nice
okay and then i'll make sure i got the right
all right and then i gotta change the artwork like a
selected artwork for it but also i'll tell you guys the
story i'll tell you guys um san francisco story too what it
was like San Francisco.
So I did a lot of stuff in San Fran.
Let me see.
I wrote it down.
Oh, yeah.
I also did not realize.
I did not realize that gaming news are released at a
convention about games.
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's some money to help with your gotcha addiction.
Unfortunately, due to tariffs, it's all I could afford.
Thank you for the super chat.
thank you i literally forgot i didn't i didn't realize
invention about video games called gamescom would be
releasing news about video games i did not realize if i'd
known guys i swear i swear if i had known i would have
absolutely streamed did a
I just didn't realize.
I just, I don't know.
In my head.
I just was just thinking that it was just a, I don't know.
I realized it's a convention about gaming.
So of course they'll have gaming news.
But like in my head, I was like, it's like, I don't know.
I was just like, oh, it's a convention about like gaming.
But there's good.
They're not going to announce anything because it's in
Europe.
Like, I don't know why.
thought that.
I was just like, I was just like, oh, it's in Europe.
They're not going to announce any video games.
They're just going to preview some games there.
I was like, it's too early to announce video games.
I don't know why I thought that.
I was just like, they won't announce video games there.
I don't know why I just thought they're just gonna have like
game previews like you know It's just a convention to like
play video games, but now I don't know why I'm in my head I
was just like they're not gonna announce anything there like
there's no announcements there No, no, I don't hate my brain
just couldn't comprehend it for some reason I was just like
I saw it.
I was like, I don't know.
I just thought it was like a normal convention.
Yeah, so I was like, there's other gaming presentations
other than the summer game fest and the game awards and this
because like, you know how like there's all these
presentations, all these like companies doing their own
presentations to like Nintendo Direct and the Sony, I don't
know, the play, I don't even remember what they're called,
the play, play whatever.
Sony gaming preview streams.
What the fuck?
Stay to play.
You know, I just think like stay to play Nintendo Direct,
the, the Microsoft one, the, there's so many.
So then I don't know why it's just in my head.
I was just like, there's no way they can fit another one.
You know, Like, we just got so many other gaming previews.
There's no...
I was like, there's no way.
Oh, yeah, and I forgot about the Tokyo...
I already forgot about the Tokyo Game Show, too.
I forgot about Tokyo Game Show.
Yeah.
So it was so...
It was, like, so hard to keep track.
And I was like, oh, it's so early.
There's no way.
It's gonna be game announcements that early and then I
forgot because I never do Nintendo direct because of this
reason Because they're always so early Like like that's why
like Nintendo direct also is not like it's not real in my
head because it's so early So anything that's too early.
I was like, it's not real It's it doesn't exist in my world.
It's like that's like don't pay attention to Nintendo And
I'm like, I'm not waking up at 5 in the morning to find one
game I like in your presentation.
Usually, it's like for one game release that I'm sort of
looking forward to.
Like in Nintendo 2 right now, it's just like, yeah, yeah,
no, no, I'm good.
I'm fucking good, bro.
one game is like me like being hopeful me being positive of
the experience with high expectations is one game and then
but like was there any it was there any hype games that they
announced someone said it was heroes of might and magic
remake but then like i looked at the graph like i looked at
the trailer and i was just like all right I don't know.
It looks weird.
The trailer I don't know.
I don't know if I fuck with it.
I think that's it.
I don't...
The heroes of mine and I looked at it really quickly.
I don't know if I fuck with the graphics of it.
It looks a little weird.
I'm looking at it again.
It looks...
Oh no.
I just liked the old graphics more you know the old graphics
was more um nostalgic i think that's the right word the
older graphics are much more nostalgic and much more all the
old timey whiny shit it's good but balance more for yeah it
has a charm of its own so i don't know if i like the new
graphics of the remake it had soul i guess yeah um cyber
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you this past
sunday was actually my birthday alas it's my 40th which
means any second i'll wither and fade to dust as my last
request can an ancient dragon get one final happy birthday
cyber with kamioshi oh my god grandpa he'll be okay grandpa
i'll scorch you Get up, stay in your bed, old goon.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Saver.
Happy birthday, Saver.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
What else did they announce for the Gamescom?
I feel like I didn't hear much about the announcement other
than...
other than Heroes of Might and Magic, but only because I was
tagged on it, so I don't know.
You guys know?
What else was there?
New Mega Man?
Witcher 3 DLC?
Nothing new?
Yeah, but all these are like games we already know that's
coming out.
There's a new furry dog game all right let me look this up
games com announcements like i said it was just so early
that like anytime like if there's like announcement stuff
going on and it's too early for me like it's like especially
in you if it's like a european uh event like i won't be
awake i i will not be awake for that so in my head it does
it like doesn't process me that like it's happening and even
i feel like even if i known that gamescom was gonna do what
if gamescon had gaming announcements i don't think i would
have woken up for it i don't think i'd be strong enough i'm
100 would not have been strong enough um think of a super
chat lali thank you thank you have you have you given heroes
of my magic olden era try it been pretty neat they give a
super chat thank you thank you no i haven't yet um i've been
wanting to for a while but definitely we'll check it out in
the future but i know gamescom is like i don't know why i've
always known about gamescom but it's because it's like the
biggest gaming convention in europe but in my head it just
doesn't click i i don't know why i was just like there's
there's no gaming announcements during that day i don't know
why i think my head just doesn't process it and i was like
it's too early for that it doesn't exist just like nintendo
direct it doesn't exist for me it's too early all right
gears of war okay we know about the gears of war hoyo's
verse elder ring like hoyo verse made an elder ring game
what is this Yeah, they're already announced this if you
ignore your existence.
Thank you for the super chat, Honduras.
Thank you.
We always go watch it a lot like we never watched it before.
We would...
When have we done something like that?
What do you mean?
Or are they going to gotcha the kick?
Wait, how is this going to work?
How is there going to make a soul's leg?
How are they going to...
Is there going to be gotcha?
in my souls like game now I assume like it's they're not oh
is the characters gonna be gotcha paywall I mean it looks
cool I'm just curious how how is this gonna work on a gotcha
company it's not a it's not a oh my god did are they making
this game out of passion
A game made of passion for gaming?
No way.
Where there's no battle passes or there's no monetization
within the game.
No.
Oh my god.
Are we in an alternate universe right now?
Are we impossible?
That's crazy.
All right.
New Rainbow Six Tactics.
Anada.
Okay, I heard about Anada.
That was a GTA.
No pay to pay?
No pay to...
No bico transactions?
Where am I?
all right the silent hill that's the one we know already
right that yeah that's we've seen that already tides of
annihilation um i don't really know much about that one uh
oh there's a new mega man game right apparently they
announced a new mega man or something uh game of war if
there war for sure off shows off its gameplay what's this is
a oh the game of throne strategy game uh i haven't seen the
trailer they showed the okay new trailer for a mega man dual
override oh my god they added oh my god there's finally
another girl in mega man say it ain't oh my oh my okay she's
cute though he's pretty cute um all right so there's a new
twinkle girl so there's a new mega man game coming out we i
remember we heard about it before but this is when they
first show the trailer is that it is all the new games uh
thousand threads threads of meson metro new gameplay hitman
takes on snoop dog okay that i'm there okay that's that's
funny you i you can kill snoop dog it man that's like crazy
oh my god all right um the new madman oh a new mad max game
did it announce that before or no or is that is that new is
that one new oh there's a new oh yeah there's an animal
crossing oh yo verse game too that one i can see gotcha in
it i yeah okay so they did announce before a new Mad Max
game.
It's a survival strategy game.
Holy shit, that is loud.
There's no gameplay trailer.
It's all CGI right now, but apparently it's a Mad Max
survival strategy game.
And then there's an Animal Crossing there's an Animal
Crossing Hoyoverse game, which I know that's going to be.
I mean, Nintendo does that with Pocket Camber Ready, so
like...
That one, I think, will definitely Definitely will have
gotcha involved for sure.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please pause this video.
I hate embed Oh my god No, it's so loud Oh my god Oh, I hate
embed youtube videos.
Holy shit Because it's like all the stuff is like Different
placements.
All right, and crazy taxi reveal That one but then they've
used ai for it, which sucks uh grab Lego sky lines.
I saw that one already.
Okay, here's my magic reveal.
Pony Island 2.
What's Pony Island?
I know a lot of people were freaking out about Pony Island.
I don't know if I played, I don't think I've played this
game before.
I don't remember if I know this game, actually.
PUBG New Battle Royale.
At this point, I'm surprised there's no PUBG extraction
shooter unless there was.
unless there was and then it's got it's been it's gone
already um let's see pony island let me see all right let me
look up pony island i actually don't know pony island um
pony island is a suspense puzzle game in disguise you're in
limbo trapped in uh oh wait what wait this is pony island I
feel like I've seen this game before but not not really um
wait this is so different from oh what the fuck this is so
different from the first game that's a cool puzzle game oh
that's interesting I never heard of pony island before maybe
I'll check it out um in the future Onimusha's demo yeah
Onimusha revealed what the fuck is murals this is another
what is this i have no idea i just skimmed through it i
don't know what that is it looks interesting though it
really does look interesting
all right so that's gamescom
doesn't look like a lot of announcement how long was the was
the announcement stream for it It doesn't look like there
was a lot of announcement.
It looks like a lot of like games we know that are going to
release, but just more gameplay trailers revealed for it.
Two hours.
This list did not look like two hours of content.
Not going to lie.
I was like, I skimmed through it and I was like, this list
did not look like two hours of trailers.
This is a fair lot of them Me skimming through the list It
looks like Um A lot of the trailers was A lot of the
announcement was just showing you Trailer Like show you just
gameplay trailers of games That were already announced Yeah
Hmm Oh yeah I heard it was the Mugenics cons I just read I'm
not heard I literally just read it I just read that they did
a Mugenics concert too.
I mean, that's cool.
They're a fucking IRL concert of Mugenics.
All right, let me grab an artwork for the schedule, guys.
Let me find an artwork for it real quick.
Bum, bada-um, no, bada-um.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
So I'm very chill maxing right now.
this always happens whenever I can't come back from
traveling I'm just I'm just chill Mac also I fucked up um
sorry I'm procrastinating from the game itself but I fucked
up and you're like Doki how what do you mean you fucked up
so when I came back so okay so I always get like um I was
getting yelled at by my friends to um to
get like what's it called global entry or whatever to get
like i think it's called global entry or uh pre-tsa or
whatever because i'm always traveling to the states too i'm
always like flying to the states for business trips and
everything so they're like you should you should fucking get
like global entry um so it's like basically it's like fast
pass uh it's a fast pass so you don't have to go through you
don't have to go through like the lines of checking in and
everything.
And then I was like, no, it's fine.
Like, it doesn't matter to me.
I can wait and lie, you know?
Yeah.
Because, like, for me, I was like, because you need to pay a
fee, too.
You need to pay a fee.
And there's, like, an application process and everything.
And I need to do, like, I don't know.
I remember it was, like, an interview and stuff like that.
And I was like, it's fine.
I'm for the people, you know?
I'm no special I'm no no not as special as anyone else in
the world I'm just like you I'm I'm just like you where I'm
for the people you and I were the same no more special than
than anyone else
So, uh, I'm the bird of the people.
But I just never felt like I needed to get it, you know?
Because I'm just like, I can't, I don't mind lining up.
I just sat there for like 10 to 15 minutes.
You stand there for like 10 to 15 minutes, and then just,
you know, you're through.
That's it.
And I always, like, I've never been, like, late because of,
um, in line and everything um and so i i never minded it you
know i never fucking minded going through it so i never got
it but i was getting badgered about it because they're like
oh it's just so convenient like you should get it you're
always traveling everything it's a business expense
technically too and i'm always traveling to the state so i
was like i was like no it's fine but then when I was coming
back from San Francisco I was trying to find the line I was
trying to find a line for regular security because there's
so many different I didn't realize this in America because
in Canada it's so easy just here's the line but in some
airports in America especially in San Francisco there were
like so many different lines on like which thing you have,
like which fast track you have.
So I was like, where's the regular line, you know, like the
for the people line, like where's the, where's the commoner
line?
Like, cause like, you know, it was like, there's three
separate lines for like global entry and like pre-TSA.
And then there's the one I didn't know about was Clear Plus.
and I was like what the fuck is clear plus yeah like where's
the line for where's the line for me like the one where for
the people you know like so so I was so confused because I
was just like because all my thing is like make sure to go
to this area so I went there and then I couldn't find the
regular line like and And so I asked this lady, and she was
like, oh, it's like all the way, like she was pointing to
the right side, I still didn't see it, you know, I was just
like, I don't know where it is, I couldn't see it, like she
just pointed there, but then she was like, oh, but do you
want to register for Clear Plus right now?
We're having a promotion right now where, technically, you
get seven day free trial, and before you pay for the yearly
membership, and now it's just like, oh, seven day free
trial.
and my stupid fucking dumb brain thought this was the thing
that everyone keeps telling me to get because i'm like i
don't know i didn't know you had three different ones like
in america you know in ghana it's just one it's called nexus
we only have one fast track thing And it's called Nexus.
And so I didn't realize in America, it's pre-TSA, global
entry, and clear.
Like, why do you have three?
Like, so, anyway.
Anyway, so I was just like, oh, this must be the one that
everyone's talking about.
I was just like, thank you.
this must be the one that everyone keeps telling me to get
and and so I was like oh you know what you know tell me
about it because like I have time you know I have time and
maybe I'll just get it since I have like I actually have to
travel three more times to states this year like confirmed
trips I have to do for this year for the end of the year so
I was just like you know what at least like I can use this
for my next three times I'm traveling to the states so so
she was like explaining to me yeah like you could to get a
discount now get like a i think it was like a 15 discount
now um or or uh you can get seven day free trial but then
get paid a full price after the seven day free trial ended
so i'm just like fucking what a deal i thought this would
take longer to get i thought there was supposed to be an
interview process or an application process but you're
telling me that i can get this right now and all i have to
do is just pay for it like wait this wasn't so hard it's
like usually i'd be like seven day free trial you know i'm
just like i'll just grab it right now but so i was like well
i might as well i was just like well everyone keeps telling
me to get this and and you know what maybe i could people
could finally stop complaining to me about why i don't have
like if i'm traveling so much why i'm not like and like, uh,
like optimizing my routes, I get it.
No, it was, like, it was one, it's like the airport staff
that told me about it.
Um, um, I didn't realize it's just all capitalism, okay?
I was, so, so I didn't realize there were three different
systems that Americans use.
So I thought it was just one.
yeah so so i was just like all right five i'll pay for it
now and then i was like oh wow so convenient i'm in the
front of the line of security and i paid for it i was like
finally now they can stop complaining about me not getting
um pre-tsa little did i know this was not pre-tsa
which was not free I didn't realize it was three separate
things that I somehow all got confused over um yeah so um so
anyway anyway I paid for it I went through I was like oh
that was so easy I thought it was a harder process I was
told there was like I thought there was like an application
process and interview stuff like that and then after I paid
for everything got through and sat down waiting for my plane
I looked it up and I was just like was this the I was like I
swear to God the one in Canada was not called clear like
I swear to God it was not called clear I'm pretty sure so I
go it I was like does Canada have clear plus and um why I
searched after because my flight was in 15 minutes so my
flight was technically in 15 to 20 minutes so I did not want
to waste time I want to make sure I got past security and
then and then um yeah Yeah, boarding was starting in 15 to
20 minutes, so I wanted to be sure I got past security
before I had time to search it up.
So, no, it was 15 minutes till boarding.
Till boarding.
And I know I had, like, at least 15 more.
Technically, I have 30 minutes.
So, no, it's not even a free trial.
already paid for it, already paid for a year, a year
subscription, a clear plus.
And so, so I Googled it and then, and I was like, does
Canada use clear plus?
And, and it, and it's been bulleted letters.
Canada does not have any clear plus machines.
And I was like, does my airport have clear plus?
Um, and what was the point?
Well, the free travel, was you can get a free trial but then
you have to pay the full price after the free trial ended or
you can pay a 15% off now and then just like just take a 15%
off and because like the free trial doesn't come with a
discount so I was just like I'll get the discount woo
discount you know like oh 15% off so I went with that route
because I thought this was the one I was supposed to get
it's it's a yearly subscription by the way and i found out
the um uh and i found out that um in canada we don't use
clear plus we don't have any machines for it we use nexus
which is basically global entry like ours is just we need
global entry for it so i was like oh wait did i buy the
wrong one and I read it was oh my gosh and then clear pus is
like it's $200 per year and that because I was like damn
that's expensive but I can use it as a business expense and
I am traveling at least three more times this year alone at
the end like I have three more travel times I need to travel
at the end of the year so I was like okay I can maybe it'll
it'll be worth it so and I was like That's what everyone
uses, right?
And I found out global entry is $100 every five years.
I was like, why would anyone get Clear Plus?
What the?
I guess because Clear Plus is paid a win, I guess.
Like, I guess if you have a record or some shit, I don't
fucking know.
Like, yeah.
So, I just think.
thinking um if you have a you get just paid to like get
extra benefits but like for a global entry slash nexus um
you have to go through an application process and it'll take
a while to get approved and you have to do an interview
apparently do interviews in canada and in america to get
approved but then if you don't want to you know if you have
something to hide i guess you do clear plus which is not me
i just got confused i have nothing to hide i I just, I just
didn't realize it was a difference.
I didn't,
yeah, $200.
No questions.
I just wanted to do an interview.
It's something to hide.
Then you go with Clear Plus.
So you don't have to have your secrets uncovered by the
government.
So, um, so I bought the wrong one I'm canceling it later
this week because it's like I already paid I just it's a
yearly subscription so I just have to cancel I mean like I
said I don't know how much I'm traveling next year I just
know in this year alone I have a lot of traveling to do for
this year alone um this is where tax is covered don't get
long yeah that's how I that's how I fucked up I bought the i
i bought the wrong fucking fast pass through security why is
there three different fucking things like i why why can't
you combine it all into one why is there three different
fucking systems just to get through tsa money joki it's all
about money all right sorry let me i still need to find a
illustration for my schedule my osu would be the gal getting
roped into pyramid scheme thinking it was a nice deal thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you solid uh next he
thank you super chat thank you thank you more importantly to
go somewhere in person to get your application process yeah
yeah i read about that i saw that too um all right i got the
illustration on me that was my little mishap for the day
well for the month
for the week actually i think it'd be easier i say for the
week something always happens to dokey part dokey bird
just a little whoopsie all right sorry guys let me all right
I'm almost done guys almost done with the schedule I'll just
post the schedule thing and I'll post like the extra stuff
later um okay August 23
let's see I assume everything is red all right let me tweak
this out now
but i'll talk about the sand friends stuff when i boot up
the game all right oops okay august 23 to August 29th.
I should be good.
And I'll upload it onto...
Upload this.
Onto our schedule.
Waiting room.
Oh, no, no, no.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, all right
done all right so happily you're in sm near where i was
employed for work next time you're in sm hit me forward
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yo okay i
did not realize san francisco that san francisco was so
expensive i did not realize it was such an expensive place
to live in because i forgot silicon valley is in san franc i
don't know why that's okay i know silicon valley is like you
know i know silicon valley is like you know silicon It's
somewhere in America, but like, in my head, I always see it
as like, like its own area, you know, like, like,
everything, I can rest, everything is in California, you
know, yeah.
Yeah, I thought LA was more expensive than San Francisco,
because LA is like where Hollywood people are, you know,
like, all the people in Hollywood and, um, entertainment,
like every voice actor, every streamer.
lives in LA technically or Texas because of tax because you
don't have to pay taxes for entertainment um that's why you
see a lot of streamers either live in Texas or in LA but
anyway I didn't realize that San Francisco is where all the
tech people are like uh where all like the um you know the
tech bros live in uh Silicon Valley so there's so many like
Teslas and cyber trucks and all that shit all like the rich
people like there's oh my god you can like uh I was like in
that area with all the um because I went to the Nintendo
store to check out like uh if there's like um anything I
want to buy at the Nintendo store which I did I bought some
stuff at Nintendo store because I saw there was like
Splatoon stuff and uh and Pikmin stuff that I wanted I
wanted because I wanted to buy a Pikmin hoodie that I wasn't
able to buy in Tokyo because I didn't have time to go to
Tokyo Nintendo store so I saw they had it in the San Fran
Nintendo store so I was like oh I have to get that because I
wanted to have like the yellow Pikmin hoodie which was which
was really cute um and also I forgot to fucking bring a
jacket did not realize it was so fucking cold in San
Francisco because it's not cold where I am right now it's
actually like pretty hot where I am right now um I was so
stupid because I for I didn't bring a coat because I was
like oh it's so hot where I am Kurt like where I live so
like um um surely is is like just as hot in San Francisco I
didn't realize because they wrote me they wrote like a
little uh to-do list or like a little guide on like what to
bring and like what to expect and then they had a little
header there for weather and then I didn't read that part
right everything else but the weather I brought t-shirts and
shorts by the way and then it was like in the weather tab
the weather header it was like prepare for days were
partially cloudy overcast and then they gave me the
fahrenheit degrees as if i fucking know how to convert
freedom units and so as i was like 60 fahrenheit that sounds
so hot and so it's like mid 50s to 60 wow that sounds so hot
and san francisco often has foggy mornings and is windy and
I did not read that apparently I I was so cold and so I was
like I have to buy at least a jacket I thought about it too
at the beta I was like oh should I bring a jacket oh I don't
want to hold the jacket around anyway instead I bought a
jacket okay and then I'm so fucking stupid so if you guys
didn't know I went to Alcatraz you guys don't know what
Alcatraz is it was like one of I actually don't even it's
one of like the most haunted prisons in America because a
lot of people died there and there was a lot of like bad
things that happened in Alcatraz even though Alcatraz only
survived for like what 40 years or some shit but apparently
a lot of stuff happened in 30 to 40 years yeah a lot you
have a lot of things happen a lot of things can happen in 30
to 40 years
prison yeah so um I went to Alcatraz and the one time I
needed to bring a jacket I did not bring my jacket like I
did not bring I literally bought the pigment hoodie just so
I could wear it when I'm at Alcatraz when I have this
because it's so fucking cold um and so I had to I have an
Alcatraz jacket now by the way I went to the gift shop to
buy a fucking Alcatraz jacket all right yeah no there's a
ferry ride i got i was like okay andy was with me for those
who don't know who andy is like he was the one that um was
there uh he hosted the capcom show by the way um and he's
like the staff member that invited me and i uh and i asked
you know when we had all had a big dinner you know i'll tell
the story now i know i should be game you want me to tell
the story while we're gaming or tell the story right now
guys uh uh man thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Uh, did you get the blunder gag?
At least.
Thank you.
Super chat.
All right.
Do you guys want me now?
Okay.
All right.
Anyway.
So.
Um.
Uh.
All right.
I'll start from the beginning.
Let me.
So I went to San Francisco.
For those who don't know.
Capcom USA is located in San Francisco.
San Francisco.
Um, I meant, um, wait, let me redo this, telling Capcom
story, and then, and then we gave.
Uh, so for those who don't know, Capcom USA is located in
San Francisco because it's like, uh, also, it's like a, you
know, tech city.
So a lot of, apparently a lot of like, uh, gaming companies,
a lot of tech companies are located in San Francisco because
it is Silicon.
It's where Silicon Valley is.
And so I met a lot of the people who work in Capcom USA.
I met like the community team for it.
So I when I was the first one there, I was actually the
first one like there's three of us that got invited.
It was me, Ozzy and Fruit.
I was the first one there because I took the earliest flight
possible because I just wanted to like, you know, just get
be there early and like just I didn't I was scared of being
late.
But I didn't because Ozzy's flight got super delayed because
it was his only, he had only one flight to choose from and
his flight got delayed apparently because the San Francisco
airport was going through some renovations.
So, because my flight was late too, but it was like 30
minutes late.
But his was like almost an hour late.
So that's why our stream started late because he got there
and then he had to go straight to the, he had to go straight
to the studio and everything.
We just like, he got there.
We had 10 minutes to set up and then we went live.
So that's why his stream started late.
Like, because he literally got there and we went live.
We got 10 minutes to put everything on and then went live.
Anyway, so, you know, while I was waiting, I was just
hanging out with the staff team.
Like the community staff team for Capcom USA.
And got a tour of the office and everything.
I got to touch the Game Award trophies.
Like, they had all the trophies displayed there.
The Game Awards.
And, I think, like, Gag Awards.
I don't know.
I just know.
I just know the Game Award trophies.
Like, that's the most important one to me.
So let me show you guys the pictures.
Let me see.
The ones I posted on Twitter.
So let me see.
Did I take any other pictures outside of the ones I posted?
All right.
Let me.
see let me show you guys so they have different the cool
thing about the office i took pictures of a lot of stuff so
the cool things about the office is that they have a lot of
different rooms dedicated to uh several of their ips so um
also i was i was like uh i was laughing at how uh they put
like funco pops at the bottom of the shelf below like the
words that they received and they're like we just they were
like uh annie was like we had to put something like i had to
like fill up the space and like so it was just easier to it
was easier to just put like funko pops because there's so
many it was like we had to figure out how to fill up the
space you know so i thought this was really cool so you know
it was an entire shelf by the way this entire row so this is
just one of the so this is like half the row like not even
half one-third of the row because the entire row was just
all the awards they received over the years for their games
and everything so this is just like one-third of the row
that i took pictures of so you know and then uh each room
had a little is decorated so if they have a meeting for a
certain game it's capcom usa you know they do localization
and stuff like that and do like community outreach and uh pr
and stuff like all the you know andy is runs like almost
like runs and he and his team runs all the social media
accounts for like uh uh for all the games under capcom so
you know and all the uh events and interviews and stuff like
that he runs all like him and his team runs all of that so
they have little offices dedicated to uh because obviously
the yeah like main office is in japan you know so they'll
have like meetings and stuff with the Japan management team.
It was Capcom Japan.
So for specific games, they have all these offices dedicated
to each specific game.
So for example, they would have a meeting with, you know,
the Phoenix Wright team.
You know, the dev team, developers in charge of Phoenix
Wright.
So they'll have like, they'll go to the office that's
dedicated to it.
So I thought it was really cool.
They dedicated it to like a courtroom basically, like a
courtroom vibe and everything.
and so like it looks like an actual courtroom yeah and then
there's the there's a white bar that says objection and
everything and then so there's also the monster hunter
office too so here's the monster hunter office uh so like on
the monster hunter team and there's more to it it's actually
really cool uh so they'll have like all of that and then
there was like there was like monster Let me see.
So there's like, you know, monster hunter props and stuff,
which was really cool.
I could, like, we could pick them up and everything.
So we could pick up these props, by the way.
There was a lot of them.
There was a lot of monster hunter armor and props scattered
around the offices.
So it's not just that.
There was, like, a sword in the broadcast room.
So there was also a broadcast room where they do, like,
their interviews.
their uh streams and all that and then there was like a lot
of props there as well and then there was a street fighter
room um i didn't take a lot of pictures of like all the
angles so here is the street fighter room yeah i was able to
pick all of them up they're so heavy by the way they were
they were so heavy so so and this was the street fighter
room i only took a picture of half
There was also the Resident Evil room.
Let me see if I can grab that.
The Resident Evil room was pretty cool.
Let me see.
Let me grab the pictures real quick for that.
Um.
Yeah, I didn't do like the 360 of it.
I just took a picture of the wall.
Just because I was like, there's the why.
There was a Mega Man room too.
Um, some rooms were more decorated than others.
um okay i'll show you the resident evil room so the resident
evil room was the biggest room out of all of them so it was
like a giant meeting room and it had like the capcom uh logo
on it so this was the resident evil room and you're like
that's it's just that it and there's like uh i didn't see
that that was so funny okay then there's the other um like
the how the TV has like hello TV's just like hello and then
on the walls was the map of the village map too um right
here so on like on one of the walls for the Resident Evil
room was just a giant map of the village.
And then there's me right here.
And then there the Mega Man room was not really anything
special.
It really only had it really only had like this there, which
was apparently a really rare figure.
A really rare, very hard to get.
So this was the one thing they had in the Mega Man room.
So I took a picture of that and then there's like in the
entrance um In the entrance, it was a giant Chun-Li statue.
I was like, ooh, getting kidnapped by a giant woman in
Capcom.
Because that's sort of what was happening.
So, this is me getting kidnapped by a giant woman at Capcom.
And if you guys didn't see the Twitter pictures I posted.
let's see
there's like oh is that the picture I wanted to save and
there's me next to not that one whoopsie
bum bum bum bum bum so there's me next to a giant another
giant woman
um but But yeah, that was like the Capcom office was so
interesting.
It was so cool to visit.
Oh yeah, they had the Meg.
I forgot to show this one.
They had like a little Mega Man collection too.
Um.
On another wall.
There's this as well.
So there's like a big Mega Man collection on one of the
walls that's connected to, uh, that's connected to like the
main offices.
Which I couldn't go in.
Like the, like where all the people were working at because
they were like, yeah, like.
just for legal reasons you know there'll be like you know
there might be like sneak peeks of future games or like
legal documents or someone's pc or that's like left on the
desk so they're like yeah you're not allowed in that room
you're allowed everywhere else it's not in the offices so um
so that was like the one area i couldn't i was not allowed
to access uh but this was next to picture of that uh but it
was it was a really and then there was like um apparently i
also got went into like the i think it was like the the the
head chief's office too because he wasn't there that day so
but like in it was just like a poster of the first street
fighter movie of a like a sign poster of let me see if
there's any reflections on here before i show it and that's
the most that office they had like uh um basically like
signed photos of each act like each actor uh of each of the
main characters that were in the very first street fighter
movie and i thought that was really cool because a lot of
these actors have passed away too there's a little
memorabilia from the very first street fighter movie let me
double check just let me do a little double check the yeah
they're fine but this was in the this was in the it's not
ceo but it was like the the head the head chief of capcom
usa is this ceo of capcom usa i guess it could see you of
capcom usa but this was in his office um which i was allowed
in to just take a look and just take picture of it i thought
it was really really cool they even have like the autograph
of bison too you can see on the far right over on the one
far right pictures.
So i did a little tour, i did a little game show for Andy.
It was really fun.
I talked to like the staff, like the rest of the team under
like that because Andy's like the leader of the community
management team and I talked to like the other staff members
there and just like hang now and just like got to know them
more um and you know i asked about some stories and stuff
about uh about like you know being like what's the craziest
things you like you received in the mail from capcom for
capcom usa because like uh okay so before that they're
telling us how capcom usa office used to be on the first
floor people would like stock the offices and Because, you
know, it's very like if you Google Capcom USA address, it'll
show up.
So they had to actually move offices to a higher floor
because people were like, because they were on the first
floor originally.
So they had to move the office to the, to a not second
floor.
I won't talk to the floor, but I don't even know if it's
like it's in the eye.
But it's they had to move at a higher floor.
And then it's still there.
like and like and then so um so like they're telling me how
like people would show up like at the office and then like
peek through the windows to see what they're doing so i was
like i was like oh my god that's so scary and weird they're
like yeah so we have to move because people keep trapped you
don't think we're like capcom japan where we're like the dev
team but like you know we all know the devs are in japan so
but uh capcom usa does mostly the localization and like
doing hosting the events, hosting the, um, helping with
like, uh, previews and stuff like that and like previewing
the games and stuff at different conventions in NA and EU
and stuff like, like, you know, they, they work on all of
that.
And so, so, um, so, uh, they're saying how like, yeah, they
had to move offices because people would just camp out at
the office, like outside the office and just peek through
the windows, just seeing what they're doing.
So I was like, That's, that's creepy.
And I was like, all right, so like, you know, what's the
weirdest you've ever received?
Like, what's the weirdest thing you've ever, that's ever
happened at the office?
Or like, what's the weirdest thing you've ever received?
You know, because they have a, you know, they have, they
obviously received mail and stuff.
So they're talking about how they have, oh yeah, they'll
have like graduation, marriage, like marriage letters, like
invitations to people's graduations or marriage or baby
showers and stuff like that because they, because those
people would want them to see it.
They'll send free swag, free merch over to the offices, you
know?
And they're like, oh, yeah, like we don't, we try not to, we
don't send anything because we don't want to set like a
precedence.
Be like, oh, look, they sent us stuff.
So then like other people would ask for things too.
So they're like, oh, but we always receive like invitations
to graduations to marriage.
And then apparently one time they received a baby shower
invite for their newborn baby who they named Leon Rathalos
Kennedy and I was like and they were like Kenny by the way
was not the last name so someone named their baby Leon
Rathalos Kennedy I think it was like Leon's the first name
and I guess Rathalos Kennedy was the middle name and
and yeah so they say they and they and they sent like an
invitation a baby shower um to them being like hey you want
to come to leon rassel's kennedy's baby shower and um and
then they were telling i was like oh what's the sweetest
package you ever you know you know from the pros and the
cons and And I asked them, like, oh, what was the sweetest
letters slash package they've ever received?
Like, what's the best package?
And they're telling me how one time a kid sent a doll.
And they asked them if they could take pictures of the doll
all over the offices and then send it back to them.
And then one of the staff member was like, oh, but we didn't
send it back in time.
And I was like, what?
What do you mean you didn't send it back in time?
Did he die?
I was like, you know, the way he said that?
I was just like, did he die?
What do you mean?
Like, and then he was like, no, no, no.
It was for a school project.
So like, we passed the deadline.
Like, it was like, no, it was a school project.
So they passed the deadline to send it back in time so like
so like they didn't make it in time for like his school
project But they didn't do it and I was like oh my god.
I was like what do you mean?
He didn't send it back like what?
Yeah, they should have started it out.
I was like oh my god His final wish was to have this doll
and pictures sitting around the office and you didn't send
it back in time.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Poor kid got an F on his school project.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Reminds me when Bethesda offers three free copies of all
Bethesda games for life.
And they named their child Dova came back when Skyrim was
coming up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, the kid is alive.
He just failed his school project.
anyway okay so um drink dinner so after the whole thing um
um obviously capcom paid for dinner for all of us and we're
like let's get sushi because you know it was a japan game
show so the obvious thing to do is to get japanese food so
um you know i was like okay so So there was a, so it was
like a really, it's San Francisco.
For those who live in San Francisco or know how expensive
San Francisco, it's San Francisco.
Like, let's just say it was very expensive.
So, but then it was all on Capcom.
You know, it's all on Capcom's budget because it is
considered like a streamer, like a streaming event or
something.
community uh outreach event so or like a creator like
creators event uh with the streams and stuff that we did so
so everyone else they're like okay we'll order like you know
they all order their own thing on the menu i was like oh
what should i get and then i saw on the board it was omakase
chef's choice so like you know chef's choice dishes and
everything so so i was just like oh wait that's interesting
and then and then but then it doesn't tell me the price you
know it doesn't tell me how much it costs it was like
omakase so it's like a bunch of these just basically the
chef will send a bunch of stuff and then and then i looked
it up and it's like it sent in like 20 dishes going It's
like, you know, it's just like, but it's like me, me
goodies.
So it's like, you know, there's like 15 pieces of sushi and
then like, and then five appetizers.
And then it was like, I looked at the price because you can,
there's no prices on the board or anything or on the menu.
It's not even on the menu itself.
And then I looked it up online because I was like, what's in
this?
Because there's no details whatsoever.
It just says 20 dishes.
and I looked it up and I it was like $160 per person
and I was like that's the one I'm gonna order
I was like that's the one I'm gonna order I was like, free
is free.
I'm gonna, I'm getting my money's worth.
And it's not even my money.
I'm, thank you, Capcom.
I, it's a business expense, guys.
It's, no, no, you can't be like, they're not, guys, the
crazy thing is, after we paid for the bill Andy was like oh
my god we're so under budget and I was like Tim I was like
you're welcome it's just like oh my god we're so under
budget we're not even close to like our budget for the meal
I'm just like you're welcome Andy I mean I helped I it could
have been lower
guys it could have been I could have I could have been lower
because it was like because he gets the because if you guys
didn't know like usually in business like you pay for like
if you're a staff member you pay for it and then um and then
uh the company reimburses you so it was on you know it was
on Andy's card so he would get points from it So I was like,
you're welcome, Andy, for those points.
I helped.
Yeah.
So, anyway, it was so, okay, but the, I flew.
Okay, I sort of even, it was so good, by the way.
It was actually so good.
You tell the difference, because like, okay, but I flew.
I flew too close to the sun because I only had three dishes
come out while everyone else finished their meals because I
don't know we were like joking I was like are they like
fucking like they're like actually catching the fish right
now or some shit and they're like importing the ingredients
right now to make my meal they're Counting each rice grain
one by one to make my dishes.
So everyone was done eating and they were all just waiting
for me.
And I was only three out of 20.
Get a catch here, friend.
But you can tell the difference in quality between my sushi
and the others.
Like, wait, I'll show you guys a picture.
like like it's like i was like already catching these fishes
live right now like what the fuck is going on and why it's
taking 20 years all right let me see i even had to ask
because like i was like do i have more coming like i'm so
confused i was like is more coming like okay okay the
quality okay i'm The quality might not be the best, though.
All right, wait, this one.
Oh, I'll show you that.
There's a tiny little crab there, too.
You can tell.
Like, you can tell this is, like, fancy-ass sushi, too.
Here.
There's a tiny-ass crab, but...
Like, you can tell that's fancy-ass high-quality sushi.
with the way it's played it yeah it was fucking it was
fucking delicious um but like i said everybody was just
waiting for me i felt so bad i'm like i'm so sorry guys i
flew too close to the sun i'm ordering this one i oh this
was bone marrow this was crazy it was like it was so good it
was like bone marrow um oh i oh no that crab was to be eaten
i didn't eat the crab i gave it to Ozzy because I didn't
want to because you're supposed to eat the whole thing and I
was like I don't think I'm gonna do that everything tastes
better when it's free exactly only the finest of delicacies
and ingredients for Lord Doki bird Ojo Sama wild word thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you so so you tell
this is fancy ass sushi So, um, so that's what I, uh, I even
get a little sorbet at the end too.
I didn't take a picture of everything.
At some point I stopped taking pictures of the food because
it took so long to arrive.
I couldn't, I could not wait anymore.
I was just like, at the moment it arrived, I was like, yum,
yum, yum, yum.
I just stopped taking photos.
Because I was just like, I, I lost count of how many dishes
arrived too.
Like, I actually lost count.
I didn't know where we were at anymore.
there all right let me refill my water real quick i'll be
right back
uh zander cyber meddy solid stuff thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh good thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh sawa got any crap i had to feel
some pets strong little boogers thank you for your
storytelling thank you for super chat thank you thank you um
i had a feeling the restaurant was not owning them as pets
but i'm not sure yet i'm Um, I have a little bit of a
feeling, um, they were not pets there.
Just, just, just a little bit.
Uh, but yeah, uh, but it was really good.
Shout out to Capcom for paying for my dinner.
Um, but anyway, so after the dinner, um i stayed an extra
day everyone else flew back the next day because but i
didn't want to do that because i felt like i you know i came
all this way here i never been to san francisco before uh i
came all the way there i didn't want to do like you know
just did the event like and then um because i i felt like i
didn't like i flew over uh hanged out the office till like 4
p.m like i was there at 11 a.m.
and I hanged out all the way till 4 and then only uh rested
a little bit back at the oh yeah also I didn't go to my
hotel only because I thought like you know usually it's like
checking at 3 you know and um and so like I thought I didn't
realize that uh fruit uh fruit cake was telling us like oh
yeah no I checked in and I was like how did you check in it
says check in at 3 and it's like oh they had room so then I
just checked in early and then walked done that I was like
oh my god I just chapped out the offices because I thought I
had nowhere to go because like because I was like we're only
the others so where are they and then Andy was like oh um
Aussie's still waiting on his like still on his flight and
then he was like I don't know about fruitcake she should be
here soon and then she was like oh she's here but she's just
wandering around san francisco i was like with her suitcase
like what is she doing wandering around like why not just
come over here and apparently it's because she was already
checked in and she was just like you know just exploring the
city uh you know and so like me camping it out in the
offices like just camping it out until everyone was here um
because i i just thought that like usually hotels wouldn't
let you check in until three but they had rooms available
but i didn't know that i guess it's because like by the way
for those who don't know pokemon worlds is happening in san
francisco also but it's like this next week slash this week
so like people were i assume that like nobody's flying in
yet everyone is still um you know it's not like the busy
season like the busy week yet so there was still a lot of
rooms just because like no one is actually there now for now
um so so uh so uh i didn't really have much to do i was just
like uh i literally just at four i just went and i had to
wait like 30 plus minutes for my uber to my hotel uh just
because there was like i didn't there's so many traffic
there's so much traffic jam it's like new york city like the
traffic is just new york city um esk and so i only had like
an out like like i think like and i just like brought it
this associate and zoned out in the hotel bed for an hour
until i had to go to dinner and so and after dinner i just
went back to hotel and then fucking passed out so i was like
i'm gonna say i i told annie or like i told capcom that i
wanted to stay an extra day because i knew that was gonna
happen i knew i wasn't gonna do much uh on the first day so
i didn't want to fly back to back to canada after just hang
out for like barely a day in san francisco so i asked for an
extension to stay one day longer um and just changed like
you know i just paid for an extra day like i paid for the
extra day for the hotel It was a free trip, but they were
only paying for, you know, like the, the one day hotel and
then to and back, uh, the flights to and back.
By the way, they gave me economy plus, oh la la, I felt so
fancy.
Like I'm not, this is not irony, by the way.
I'm not like joking, by the way.
It's like, I got like, if, if like any company or event pays
for something more than just economy, I'm like, oh la la.
special I feel so special I did not expect economy plus not
gonna lie I'm so used to just getting economy tickets and
then I upgraded myself if um if I have to because so I was
like oh economy plus I feel like I'm a princess it's the
little things you know it's actually the little things I
feel so pampered I
So um batch and me I was like oh my god economy plus I felt
so happy when I saw my seats were there
Anyway um so after the dinner after the dinner I asked and
like I asked like not just at any but everybody Everyone the
team and also like Aussie and fruity like oh what do I do in
a San Francisco I was going to say Los Angeles.
What am I going to do in San Francisco?
Because I've never been here in San Francisco.
I don't know what people do in that city.
So, and then Andy was like, you should go to Alcatraz.
And I was like, wait, Alcatraz?
I didn't even realize Alcatraz was in San Francisco.
I don't know.
I knew it was an island.
I just didn't know where it was located in the States.
So, so I was like, oh my God.
Wait, the prison?
So I was like, Annie, you gotta come with me to Alcatraz.
And then he was originally busy on that day.
And so, but then he was like, okay, if we get a night tour,
we can go to Alcatraz.
I was gonna pay for everything, but then he paid like what,
because he was like, if you can get tickets, I'll come to
Alcatraz.
Because I was like, I'm not going to Alcatraz by myself.
I feel like it was a little sad if I went to high security
prison by myself.
prison because I was like what if I bring back a ghost you
know what if I bring back a a prisoner with me and then if I
have someone with me at least the ghost has to choose
between one of us um so what do I get haunted like like what
if it's like a grudge scenario uh um so so uh so Annie was
like if you get a night tour I'll come with you I was like
bet and i was gonna pay for everything but then he paid he
was like he paid me back too and he didn't have to but he um
he like paid me back as well for the tickets um and he
actually never been to alcatraz he was like yeah i lived
here for my whole life never been alcatraz because it's like
a touristy thing to do but then now he has an idea of like
maybe doing a creator event at alcatraz in the future and i
was like oh my god you should totally do it and also invite
me to i was like oh my god you should totally do it and also
invite me over again So, invite me over to another free trip
to San Francisco.
So, we went, before I went to Alcatraz, I decided to like,
you know, I looked up what to do in San Francisco.
And apparently, around the same, like, on the same day for
the weekend, they were doing a cultural re-indulgence.
enactment fair like you know Renaissance fair so um they
were because okay I forgot about that so for those who
didn't know San Francisco was like the wild west back then
so they did like gold like you know the gold rush and
everything people went to San Fran to pan for gold and it
was like the wild west and all that stuff like that's where
the the gold rush came from and so I didn't know that I I
don't keep up with American history as a Canadian I'm very
ignorant when it comes to
Yeah, so I was like, Holy shit wait, I want to check it out
before like, you know, because I had time so I was like um
Um So I was like oh shit like you know, there I have
something to do the past the time Uh, while I you know wait
till the night tour Uh the night tour of the alcatraz night
tour
So it was like a, it was like a Renaissance fair, but what
if it's the Wild West?
So everybody, I didn't even know the thing, there were like
reenactment characters too, walking around, but then there
were like, like actual LARPers, like not like, you know, not
the current term of LARPing, but like people, you know, like
the Renaissance fair where people would dress up for the
Renaissance fair, but then like for this one, people were
dressing up as if it was the Wild West era.
It was so fucking cool.
I didn't know who was like, I couldn't tell who was a guest
or, who was a reenactment performer there because like there
were so there were like kids dressing up too and everything
it was so cute there was like kids dressing up and and sorry
let me see if I can find photos and alright I'm going to
grab this video and also like elderly up and like there was
this group of late old ladies who were talking about their
outfits were like custom made like they made these outfits
themselves and everything i was like that's so cool i was
like can't please take a picture of you guys because i was
like sitting next to them and they were talking about like
oh yeah i made the i made like we made this ourselves and
everything and i was like oh my god that is so cool let me
show you guys a picture i asked if i could take a picture of
them because i was like whoa that is so interesting so they
made this outfit like these old
fit themselves uh i guess to like go to the to the wild west
fair and they look like you know with the wigs and like hats
and clothes and everything i was like holy shit that's so
fucking cool i've never been to like i've never been a
renaissance fair before i've never done like um i've never
been to a renaissance fair i've never been to like an actual
like larping event where people actually like dress up and
stuff and pretend it's like that type of era so it was a
really cool experience and um so i went to saloon i was
gonna take picture of the front part of the saloon but then
there was nick it was i didn't realize when after i took a
picture of it i didn't realize there were like um it was a
naked woman not like fully naked it was a naked mermaid so
the boobs were out the titties were out so then after i took
a photo at the entrance of it i was like oh shit that's a
titty not just one set of titties there were two sets of
titties uh
so yeah so i was just like well i can't show that like it
was like half naked mermaids uh decorating it so let me see
if i can find um all right this is like what's the set by
the way no way too dude sets oh my god not enough hands for
those also this was the recording setup um for the area uh
so there's a room for that where they do all their
recordings and everything um no it was a sign guys not
actual it was like a mermaid sign i can't show it on stream
or i'll have the stream demonetized or gated r18 share the
class mr muffins thank you I can't, guys.
You know I can't.
You know I can't share it with the class.
All right, let me say I can find it.
Oh, yeah.
Also, there's a ferry ride to...
Also, I'm going...
There's a ferry ride to Alcatraz.
And, like, it was so windy.
And, like, at first, Andy and I sat on the top just to see
Alcatraz, the island of Alcatraz.
And then, like...
And then I got like dunked by water.
But I was walking down the stairs.
And then I was just like, nope, inside time.
I was walking, because I wanted a hot dog.
So I was just like, I'm going to, I was like, Andy, I'm
going to go downstairs and grab a hot dog.
And then the moment I went down the stairs, a giant, a giant
fucking wave hit me in my back.
So my entire backside was wet, dude.
So there's me looking at Alcatraz Island.
Let me see, I can...
Oh, yeah, and this was my favorite part of the Wild West.
Let me see if I can grab it.
Do I have, like, a video thing I can show?
It's just media source.
Yeah, there it is.
All right.
This one's my favorite part.
I hope I don't get demonetized.
Not the naked mermaids, guys.
I'm not talking about the naked mermaids, but this was my
favorite part.
Babe.
Bum.
doing the can-can they're doing the can-can guys they're
ruining and tuning everybody that was my favorite part of
the saloon there was also other performances obviously not
as good as the can can it was obviously not as good as the
can can guys it makes out scandalous all right let me see
there's other photos um let me check the other performances
let me see i'm trying to figure out which one to show you
all right so there's also this one that i can show you guys
as a preview of my next outfit
so it was pretty cool i never like i said never uh i've
never like been to these types of events before so i thought
it was such a cool unique the encounter and everything so
yeah i bought myself some i bought like some bakery stuff i
didn't buy anything physically i didn't buy any like
souvenirs from it um just because like i didn't really have
like my bag was sort of like stuffed with my tomato plushie
by the photoshoot so i didn't really have really have hands
to like actually buy anything i bought like a snack It was
like a cake drenched in whiskey, apparently.
It's like a cake bite.
Wait, I have it here.
An Irish whiskey cake bite.
So they were like, oh, yes, we made it with Irish whiskey.
We pour Irish whiskey into like the batch.
And then after we're done cooking it, baking it, we drenched
it again with more Irish whiskey.
And I was like, oh, that's...
And I was like, damn, wait, that sounds so good.
Yeah, we're like, yeah, no, we poured more Irish whiskey on
it.
I was like, oh, shit, you're speaking my language.
More Irish whiskey.
It's so, but it was actually really good.
It was really fucking good.
You can sort of taste, you can taste the Irish whiskey, but
then like the bread itself was, the cake itself was actually
really good.
Ah, the Irish.
They sure do know how to make a good cake.
Okay, so anyway, I'll show you more photos.
I posted it on Twitter already, but dang, who was that sexy
lady?
I mean, the dancers were cute, too.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So here's more photos of Alcatraz.
Wow, Alcatraz Island.
It was a very cool experience.
Unfortunately, the cafeteria in the hospital was under
renovation, so we couldn't go to the cafeteria and hospital
um there's me in the prison cell you know um they got me
they got it for a little bit but i escaped uh so so i was
like i was like if i'm going to alcatraz i'm definitely
getting a photo of the tomato in jail um and so it was
really cool exploring it and oh my god wait I'll show my
photos I'll also show more photos at the end of the stream
too I'll talk because I realized it's been two hours I still
haven't played the game I'm so I didn't realize it was a
yeah for so long I'm so sorry and then there's Andy there
you see Andy on the right side okay but I wanted to okay the
one thing I really want to talk about this story was when
we're about to leave let me start have the photo um when
we're about to leave um the security guard stopped me um
because they saw i had okay so i uh i won't show a picture
of it because i um but um i do this thing where every time i
go to somewhere important or um i go somewhere where i'm
traveling i would include i would buy it I either receive
something or buy something as like a souvenir from the place
I travel so my bag has a lot of like charms and bag plushies
like charm plus chart like bag charms and um like plushies
on it as like a little souvenir of like places I've been and
so this is one of the security guys while we were about to
leave the maximum security prison uh stopped me and And was
like oh my God Your bag is so cute I love your bag And um
And she was like Oh I have something to add to your
collection Um and she Pulled out like a little bag Of bag
charms And she was like Oh I had made these Um I had make
these And I want you to have one of them And I was like oh
my god Thank you I was like so Like I was like the only
person She like approached too About it too She didn't give
it to anyone else She like fucking ignored was ignoring
everybody she was just there like and if she stopped she
looked like a really tough lady not gonna lie she looked
like like i mean she is a security guide for alcatraz so so
she was like i love your bag and like it's so cute like uh
here here's something uh here i made here's something we uh
to add to your collection and then so she gave me this
little uh she gave me this uh really beautiful handmade
bracelet charm uh like bag charm basically to add so i have
it on my bag right now and i can't take picture of it
because i'm worried that um i'm because then it'll dox my
bag you know but but she then told me to show this bag charm
to this other security guard um like that we have to go to
like she was like oh if you go over there there's this other
security guard and you can tell him that you got this charm
from me and i was a little confused i was like why you know
i was just like what like why should i show this random guy
this bag charm and then i was like you know what i you know
what she's so nice i'll do it and then so um i went to this
other security guard and i was like oh hey your friend told
me to show you yeah i'm on this random side quest for some
reason i accidentally activated this random side quest and
like i said i was the one she did this to like there were
like she did not care about the others like she like did not
approach anyone else she just approached me um and so i went
to the other random security card like i was on a fetch
quest apparently and then i showed him i was like hey are
you blah blah um can um your friend told me to show you this
back charm i made uh sorry not back charm back charm she
gave me that she made and then he was like oh wait you got
charm you got a back charm from her bag bracelet oh my god
yeah she hand makes all of them and like we each have our
little bags to give up to people and then he pulled out his
bag i don't even know when he gives these out by the way
they give these out because like maybe for like kids there's
stuff but like also why would you bring a kid to alcatraz
like and then he showed me it was me and annie and then he
showed me his little bag of bracelets because his was a
bracelet so so um yeah it's like gym badges like literally
questline so the girl lady gave me a bag charm like those
like long bag bracelet charms but then the other security
guy had bracelets charms and then i saw like he was showing
me and Andy the bracelet charms and then um and then I he
showed us the bag and then I was like Andy you have to get
this and and you're like donkey what do you mean he has gay
and so I saw the moment he opened his bracelet bag I saw
this this is Andy's hand by the way
because I was like Andy you have to get this one and he's
like oh my god
And he's like, oh my god, I have to get it.
That's amazing.
And so now he has, it was made for you.
This was a canon event.
That's crazy.
Some schools that we go to, oh, it's a field.
I guess it's because it is educational.
Alicuma, thank you for saying that.
super chat thank you thank you um mr republicans thank you
super chat thank you thank you too how yeah how would this
affect the leaderboard i love it keep up thank you super
chat thank you thank you this bracelet was made for you
so so he got b gate do crime from the guy and i got the long
i wish i got one of the bracelets too but i at that point i
didn't want to be greedy you know i didn't i was just i just
didn't know what also i didn't know what the fuck was going
on like i i like i was already stunned locked by her
approaching us and being like just like had like giving me
this quest line that i had to do because we're so um so yeah
so i didn't want to be greedy and grab another the other
free one so i let annie have that like annie got that
bracelet and then i i got the the long bag charm that the
other uh the first security guard like gave to me so i got
my side quest reward uh
so so i that was why i wanted to tell you guys about that
was that was wild adventure um what else was what else i
want to tell you guys about uh let's see um also i went to
the souvenir shop and you buy like uh the rocks from
alcatraz it was like five dollars and i was just like you
like buy buy by by a rock that came from alcatraz i did not
buy a rock i bought a jacket i was so cold it was like
because it was a night tour i forgot to bring my jacket so
like at the end of the tour there was the gift shop so i was
like fuck i i need it on the ferry ride You know, we have to
wait for the ferry to take us back home So I was just like,
oh my god I need a jacket I am so fucking cold right now Oh,
yeah, it was so ominous too When we came out of the prison
Wait, let me see, I can't What did I say anything here?
Okay, yeah, so It was so ominous It felt like I was in a
horror movie So if you guys didn't know, there are like
There was like local birds native to the island of Alcatraz.
So it was so freaky because we came out of the gift shop and
then, um, so like at first it was, we just see seagulls, but
then like, but then like when you go out of the, the gift
shop, there's another, there's the other side of the island.
You're facing the other side of the island where all the
neat, these native birds, uh, are located.
And it was like, They were all black and it was so freaky
because they were all just standing there Like we never saw
these birds before by the way like on the front side of the
island you don't see them at all So um, so it was it felt
like I was in like a little Horror film like a little like a
cut like a like a spooky cutscene Or hey, there weren't even
crows by the way.
They were not crows at all and it looked like What the fuck
is that?
I'm not even sealed.
And they were just there.
What the fuck is that?
I'm not even sealed.
And it's, they're all, it's everywhere.
It is crazy when I do that.
Like, they were like, it's just the entire island.
Just on this side was just, uh, these black birds.
That's a blackboard fosher.
Okay, wait.
Let me...
Like, it was just...
It was just...
These are all the birds.
That's just...
And there were more of them, by the way.
It was just one side.
And it was, like, a lot of them on both...
Like, on the left and right side.
There were more.
There were a lot more.
And...
Let me see.
I know I zoomed...
I didn't...
I took another video.
Let me check.
that video real quick i think i know i did a zoom in oh no
that was the only video i took whoops
and but i mean it was just like there were so many and it
was so freaky because they were all just standing there and
like there were no seagulls the thing is like you don't see
any seagulls there like the seagulls would not integrate
with segregation i i don't know who's segregating who
It's like, look, there's this one seagull over there, but it
was just all, all, those birds, yeah, there is just all,
there's one, you can, it's like, where's the seagull?
So, so, but the seagulls were on the high ground, hmm, this
is a commentary somewhere, like, mostly located on the high
ground while the the blackbirds got like the the beach side
of the island and yeah and so i was like telling addie it's
so weird that the seagulls get to be at the prison and these
birds are just um so um so there's then there's like here's
That's what they're like little dots if you look at it Like
that's a lot Is this perhaps a metaphor Like This is
political bird commentary Brought to you by Doki Bird Yeah
so there were so many Okay wait That is a lot And the thing
is Like we were just we finished the we finished the the
tour and then we just came out of gift shop and then we
looked we just walked down and we're like what the fuck
because we didn't ever see we didn't see them anywhere we
were just like what the fuck was that they're all just
standing there dude they're not moving or anything they're
just like they're just standing there like all of these
birds and we never saw them and and Like, when we're going
to, when we're exploring Alcatraz on the front side of the
island, they weren't, they were, like, all of them, all of
the blackbirds, they were on the back side of the island, so
you don't see them at all until you exit the gift shop.
We're not allowed to get close to them.
I think you might know why.
They might start attacking you.
Like, I don't want to get fucking attacked, guys.
um um anyway all right that's like partial of the this
partial story of my capcom trip now we play the game i'm so
sorry i i didn't think i would yap for so long i'm so all
right after two hours we get to actually finally play the
game all right well i'll talk more about the trip at the end
the stream yeah there's actually a game guys all right story
time's over but that was my that was my alcatraz story that
update well i need them to text me because dad's coming back
any minute now and they'll text me about it um i said to
bring him back around eight so i'm just waiting for a text
to be like we're here now
all right where's my game not loading in oh my god is this
one of those games okay never mind i was gonna say do i have
to do all right i don't know what sound guys here i did yeah
for two hours i did yeah for two hours what the fuck zino
feels all right let's see this does help when you tab out um
it does the music stops i don't really like that in video
games also i played a little bit of overwatch yesterday uh
because i did want to for those who didn't know um okay i'll
yap about this um what's creators created by lots of help
from friends and oh it's credits okay all right like i said
no don't know anything about this game
this game oh yeah i realized the sound you guys couldn't
even hear the sound because it was not wrong collect all the
coal all right i see now oh wait a minute there seems to be
a game in my dokey upstream stories thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you let all code them on cards so
niachi crunchy flakes to win a million dollars no one found
the rarest card so far no one except my stupid sister coda
why stupid because She threw it away without a clue.
Oh, it's like the crypto USB.
The guy finally gave up after this year, I'm pretty sure.
So here we are, working in the garage dump to find Kotalian
and the rest of the cards.
See those trash heaps?
Walk up to one pressy to start collecting.
Whoa!
Oh my god, that's my sister!
Until it's full.
When full, drop the bag into the trash compartment to earn
some cash.
from the wedding machine outside to clean the cards you find
or glue their pieces interact with it yeah but that what
that lowers the card value this guy does not know how to
collect cards but this guy's an amateur that's not gonna
give me a psa 10.
need upgrade swim by my office dating free it's gonna be a
psa 4.
all right what's gonna say oh yeah for what the okay Okay.
Alright.
Let's just...
Alright, so for those who don't know, apparently one of our
dragoons was in the World Cup Overwatch Land in Busan,
Korea.
my clean garbage board, let's turn on the radio.
Where the fuck's the radio?
Hello?
Oh, there's the radio.
Damn nose ball.
All right.
Let's insert the radio.
All right, that's pretty relaxing.
All right, so one of your fellow dragons made it to land for
Overwatch World Cup.
And apparently, you know, I didn't realize this because I
know, like, other lands are sort of like uh you know like i
think it's mostly in japan maybe it's mostly because it's in
japan but like pro players are allowed to bring like you
know their like merchandise of their oshi to display like to
like be there with them at land where there's like keyboards
or like mouse pads or plushies and stuff like that so um but
in uh for the overwatch land they're a lot more strict about
this so they're not allowed like branded stuff uh displayed
uh during broadcast um so um so i thought like uh because
like apparently what uh it was super gomez and he wanted to
like show the plush on stream uh during like what he told me
was he wanted to do like the walkout because he had a
walkout and he wanted to show the plush on stream or like
had it with him during um during the uh matches so they
could like like have the plush like next to him during the
games and stuff so but they the staff said no they weren't
allowed to because of how strict um the broadcasting rules
was but they recognized like who the plushie was and was
like oh that's dokey bird so the blizzard staff knew who i
was and um and was like oh i know who this person like i
know this vtuber and they let him even though he couldn't
put it on display for broadcast they let him bring it up for
photos and stuff um for like them you like take photos uh of
the plush uh while he was like prep like setting up and
stuff for his matches so they let let him do that because
they're like oh i recognize who this person is um so we'll
let you take like photos and stuff with the plushies of the
stage and everything so i really appreciate that i didn't
realize they know who i was too because i haven't played
overwatch in a long time so that's why i was like oh maybe i
should like you know um get back into overwatch because i've
been wanting to get back into overwatch and they did a rank
reset recently as well so um and there's like a lot of lot
of promotion lots of like new collaborations and promotions
and stuff um with overwatch lately a lot of new updates so i
was like thinking maybe we'll stream more overwatch uh well
we might stream more overwatch in the coming weeks or
something um and just play more uh go back get back into the
ranking system of overwatch oh I have already I rank reset
and I'm already back to I'm in masters one but to be fair
the rank reset was two weeks ago so it was not that
difficult I'm so confused though I'm winning my matches very
luckily I feel so washed by the way playing Overwatch again
I was like where do I stand like I don't know where to
fucking stand in the game i'm just like i'm so fucking
confused i i keep you like i don't know where to go i was
like where is everybody like holy there's more oh my god
there's so much garbage um
grape juice oh my god I think, oh, I think this person might
be a hoarder.
Wait, I was like, I was so confused.
Oh, this bag is full.
And then turn down the music by 10.
Okay.
20 is almost like 10.
Okay, bring up overall.
All right.
Um, but yeah, that's why I want to maybe like play more
Overwatch.
um just play more overwatch uh overall on stream i have to
like get get better at overwatch again that's the thing i'm
like so washed right now like i don't like everything is i'm
trying to learn cat because cat is so strong but i i swear
to god i i'm just like i'm when i was playing cat yesterday
i'm just screaming i was like i was like i don't know what
going on I'm just flying around me like oh please I'm just a
little guy but like apparently cat is hard meta and you know
I'm a fucking meta slave I don't think for myself I I don't
think for myself I just
I just play what gives me E-Lo.
And I was just like, I was just flying around.
And me like, wee!
Please don't shoot me!
It was very, very scary.
Okay, we need more.
We need more soda.
Oh my god, I could have Yakwa playing this the entire time.
Why did no one stop me?
And I listened to all the people that told me to play this
game while I yapped because it's a yapped game.
Why didn't you yapped at me harder?
I just realized that, dude.
What do I do?
Do I have...
I have nothing.
This is my entire collection?
Oh, where'd you...
That's what it says.
I would have definitely listened.
We're talking about.
Where's the gooner pie?
Oh yeah, that's sexy pizza box.
Oh la la.
Oh my.
Oh look how sexy that bone was.
Oh, hips on that bone.
All curves on both sides.
Oh yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
talking about.
Like, where's the gooner part?
This is like the crypto bro, the crypto burrow.
Oh, hey, there's a coin.
A lot of energy?
Let me buy more soda.
Let's keep buying soda at this point.
God, I gotta work out.
oh yeah by the way so um i need one more piece of card how
the am i gonna sell this card it's in the dumpster nobody's
gonna take it but yeah anyway for those who didn't know san
francisco is hosting the pokemon world slash pokemon xp
event but like it's already a i don't know i think it's
gonna be a disaster like a disaster in a way that apparently
it's like very um bureaucratic
because apparently all right so you can't scalp any of the
tickets for Pokemon World slash Pokemon XP so you can't
resell the tickets so you have to register to get in
everything and there's no, you can't, there's no reselling
allowed for them which is good, you know, they're combating
the scalpers okay now I have to glue the card back and glue
the card back before I continue the story.
Clean the card.
What the fuck do I turn?
Oh, is this?
Oh!
Let's see.
Wait, this is Ollie.
Kotagi-Aliya.
Sorry.
I don't know.
Do I not please sit?
Does that have to be accurate?
how I piece everything.
That's cool, though.
Oh, I...
Oh, my God.
I have to rebuild it.
Oh, no.
Alright, let's glue this first.
I have to rebuild the card.
Oh, I was not.
Alright.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I was, like, wondering why it's not...
I have to glue it first before I clean it, I guess.
Or I don't have to glue it.
clean it because it's self or quality.
Yeah, I'm thinking that's going to be a one star add to it.
Oh, I can collect it, though.
Let's collect it.
Alright, nice.
Anyway, so um, so the thing about the uh, the Pokemon Royals
event is that apparently even if you buy the tickets, it
doesn't guarantee that you would uh let me grab a beer can
too just in case it doesn't guarantee that you could you'll
be able to do anything at the event itself so it's more so
like it guarantees that you can enter the exhibit but it
doesn't mean you can do any of the activities there because
there's like workshops and like pat like panels and stuff so
after you register after you get the ticket itself And by
the way, you gotta buy your flights and hotels before that.
Then, closer to event time, they open interest and stuff.
So, like, uh, wait.
I don't mean.
So they open, uh, the interest list of like, oh, what events
do you want to do at the convention?
But like I said, it doesn't, you just, you sign up for it
too.
But you also have to pay for these events if you get, uh, if
you, uh, get in.
So, so, apparently a lot of people signed up for, um, oh
yeah, I should have enough for upgrades now.
Boop.
It's a bag full.
Yeah, it was a full bag.
Let me drink a, yeah.
So even you sign up for interest, it doesn't, oh shit, okay.
How much should I have?
$900.
All right, let's see.
Speed range.
trash bags oh wait i'm gonna get the magnet i feel like the
magnet would be pretty good um capacity let's grab two beer
cans all right so even when you do an interest it doesn't
guarantee that you'll get the event so some people they sort
of also like could not stay for the full three days of the
event but then like i saw like a because i i was i was
tempted i was tempted to stay a little like, oh, you know,
maybe I could, um, maybe I could check out Pokemon Worlds,
you know, because it was only, like, you know, I could stay,
I could maybe, like, stream at the Capcom studio or
something, and, um, and, like, stay a little longer, because
I've never been to a Pokemon event before, oh, shit, I got
too busy yapping, so, I was tempted, but I've looked up,
there was no way to get tickets at all it was no way to get
anything and then people were seeing how like um the vents
were full already like to
don't worry if you can work if you have arms you can work um
and and i was looking at it and like people were like we're
like i'm there on friday and but the only events you can get
is Sunday.
And they're like, I can't, I don't know what to do.
Like, they signed up for events, but the only events they
could get was literally the one on Sunday.
So they're like, what do I do?
Like, I paid for all these flights.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Baller.
Yeah.
So they paid for it.
the flights, the hotels, and everything but they couldn't do
anything about it because um because like the only thing
that was available for them was on Sunday I mean it looked
cool I will say um I went there to check out the to check
out the also like how it's beer that's gonna me giving me
energy i'm a big ass beer belly um but like the the facility
looked really cool i like i don't know what i mean it looked
cool at least the outside part i walked through requaza road
they were still building requaza road so like i didn't
really get to see much of it because they were still
mid-building the whole thing all right let's Let's blue this
card.
Oh, there's Chibidoki!
I actually saw, oh, fuck, I accidentally drank my alcohol.
I didn't know you can drink your alcohol while you're doing
this.
Alright.
Also, why did they rip the cards out?
Like, did someone really like, was there some
anti-Chibicoda?
Gremlin Squeak stuns everyone with 3KM radius when
attacking.
I'll add this to our collection.
Keep accidentally drinking the beer i don't have a problem
like why is the card ripped to shreds did someone this must
like is chibi-doki like an ultra common or some shit they
just got their like 50th chibi-doki card and it was like the
last straw they're like i can't take it no more
kobe i realized i'm just like what was the point in me
grabbing the uh grabbing the magnet i I don't, I feel like
I'm not actually, it's not working.
I might not have read the description properly of what the
magnet does.
Oh yeah, let me show you guys the photo.
Let me see.
I took a photo of like, um, there's a little, a little
concerning that I haven't heard.
I think they forgot it was today.
all right i might need to i haven't received a text yet back
about whether or not they're coming over all right they're
like my dog now
because i said okay so i was like um would it possible to do
a dropout at night like around eight and then the morning
they just sent me a picture of my dog like sleeping on her
lap and i was just like so is i was i was like i'll take
that as a maybe
i just got sent a photo of my dog after i asked about it so
i'm gonna assume it's a maybe
Is that...
Yes.
I'll show you the photo.
I also want to show you it requires a road.
Where's that photo I took?
Yeah.
try to make sure there's like nothing all
right so like i said i i was like hey i'm sorry i have to
learn about that way but at least dad is happy this way
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys so i
you know i was just like hey um so you can drop him off
around eight is that okay and then today this morning
because i messaged that last night and she's like yeah what
time and then shoot and then at nine in the morning i got
this photo
love your yapping donkey i'm happy at a good trip it happens
to my birthday and i turned 34 i really enjoyed listen to so
it's been a pretty good birthday thank you for the super
chat um oh my god message i got at the moment i i got i got
i just got a message back i just got it he looks so funny i
got a message back i just got it back just when i talked
about it um when it talks it's like oh shit caught
actually would it be possible to drop off tomorrow at least
more time to clean the place I'm open I'm free anytime that
is that all right all right I asked if tomorrow is fine now
because I have know i was just like well now that you're
behind schedule at least i can say ask you if they could
drop it off tomorrow toky actually clean final next time on
dragon ball z so this this was them still building the area
but this is basically the pokemon xp slash worlds and then
like you know all the stuff there and this was a requiza
world that a road that they were still building and
everything that was really cool that's really cool and then
it was like let me see i did tweet a picture of it too
earlier um let's see so yeah my hotel room was actually
overlooking the the area as well so um because i like you
know i got to my hotel i was like what the is that i was
Pokemon stuff everywhere.
So you can see like the Pikachu's and everything.
Over there.
Little Pikachu's and stuff.
So it's happening this week.
Oh yeah, and then apparently.
Apparently, so because I was reading up about it, because
people were like, oh shit.
Kobe.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, hey.
Land.
What's this?
Oh, nice.
Putting the shelf is definitely planned, guys.
Uh, but Dead Chan, happy birthday!
Um, I'm glad you have been having a great birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Dead Chan.
Happy birthday!
Oh, we have a good birthday.
Okay, no problem.
Alright, cool.
Alright.
Dad's coming back tomorrow.
Also, did I tell you guys?
I told you guys the story, right?
Why?
How did I tell you guys how I figured out why Dad keeps
barking every fucking day?
Um, at me even though he's given food?
Yeah, I did.
I showed you guys pictures and videos of it.
Of him.
Getting giant ass treats, right?
So, for those who didn't hear this story yet, or forgot
about this story, but the reason why dad Always barks at me
whenever like I've already fed him and everything Is because
I found out that the dog city basically Spoils him with
treats every day.
Like lots and lots of treats every day.
Big treats, small treats.
So he's always yelling at me because I don't give him big
treats every day.
He's like, why don't you spoil me like my other mom?
I want to go back to her.
I want to go back to my real mom.
so that's why that's why he's always barking at me like i
love her more than you
so so that's why he's always so he's always barking at my
streams because he knows that's one of those that's when he
can um abuse me and know that i'm the weakest and i would
give him treats because that's when he knows that he can um
that he'll that's when he knows when to strike you know also
who's this oh i actually drink again fuck that drank all of
it okay no oh no oh okay wait
he knows he'll always win he does know holy milk i should
don't know who this is is
it not gluing together okay there we go all your light cards
gain 40 plus 40 hp who's this who's art art code uh all
right i guess i'll add to my collection i don't know who
this one is
but yeah so anyway so i just i've been like sent i've I feel
like every time the dog sitter sends me a photo or a video
of dad, it's just him with a giant hat street.
Oh, shit.
Wait, okay.
That one was a good shot, though.
All right.
Energy.
What's this?
I'm not convinced.
We'll buy more of that.
So I got more energy, too.
I feel like maybe...
Oh, we'll save more.
money yo what thank you thank you i know i'm just gaming
what can i say i'm just a baller okay so why isn't my sister
helping what the fuck is she doing i thought she was part of
this does she not want to be a millionaire oh shit okay guys
i just i'm just so buff i don't know my own strength guys
i'm not what she said yay
she's uh stuck somewhere
yeah no money for her i guess
oh wait what is what do i do here i don't uh oh i guess
these are all my cards can i like ever get like prettier
cards later i wonder like because all the other cards right
now is like fucked up yep see maybe oh my guys i'm just so
strong i'm just so buff it's just so hard to be me sometimes
well can you know like the range
oh guys oh my god it's so hard being me i just oh i just
don't know my own strength guys i just Ah, it was almost
there.
Maybe you clean them.
Okay, just aim lower.
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Okay, that works.
Ha-ha!
Alright, we figured it out.
Rebound, guys.
A close one.
Oh, I can just hold it.
I don't even have to.
the tap.
Are they even just hold it?
It's just so hard being so good at bawling.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
That's okay.
And then everyone stood up and clapped, guys.
Oh.
Now that's a shot.
That's a shot right there.
I think I figured it out.
Okay, where the fuck's my magnet?
Why did my magnet not activate?
Alright, I should.
I just need one more card.
That's right.
That's where I've peaked, guys.
Alright, let's see.
Oh.
I got another can of beer.
You gotta drink beer to make money, guys.
Oh, wait.
That's another card.
Oh!
Oh, this is a dirty card.
card Kobe all right now let's clean this uh we have one card
to clean oh my god this got taped it who's this Kota light
Kota light time works every other piece in the board game
plus 20 all right add to collection and then I got pilot oh
this is the OC I'm pretty sure
Pilot Kotoski.
Yeah, this is...
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Wow, I did not notice the rest of it.
Wow-wee.
Oh, wowza.
A whole piece was dedicated just for that.
I just I get what can I say Got all these beans for a reason
You think you need a license The pilot the wagon That size
As long as we don't get caught Guys
Damn she had entire cargo in the back Dragons
Free battle Oh simple geometry yeah I almost failed math
the bounce shot I'm like playing the what's it called that
pony what's it called in basketball like it's a basketball
game where you say like you do like trick shots but you have
to like be like oh bounce off that wall and then hit the rim
and then hoop in and you have to make the shot There's a
game for that, but I don't remember what it's called.
Pick up.
Is it called pick up?
Solid snake.
Thank you, Mr. Pritchat.
Thank you.
You could say, that show us a piece of cake.
Oh, is that horse?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I played a couple of horse in my day.
Bounce off the garbage rail, pick it up, and then hoop in.
Try and make that shot.
Oh.
Wait, I need one more.
No way.
Yeah.
I don't think you can make that shot.
Only professionals can.
Guys, I don't think it's in this pile.
I have a feeling.
I have a feeling with 10 more piles in front of me, it might
not be in the first pile.
God damn it!
I was too high.
Who keeps playing cool?
Class of O9 on my Steam's friends list.
This person's been trying to play...
Been playing Class of O9 the last three days.
It's like...
This person is now playing Class of O9.
For three days.
That's not a long game.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, I'm buying a magnet.
there's no way okay magnet pulls trash bag 1.5 okay maybe
it'll pull it high further in did it pull it oh there we go
nice all right I knew that was gonna oh wait I have a card
all right oh I got a duplicate this is why they rip this
card up she's a super mega common got another one of it i
already have it what do i do with it if i have a double do i
sell it do i add or sell it
does anyone did anyone else play this game to tell me sell
it keep it sell it i know who you are yeah the ones that are
super confident i know what you are you see i I'm playing
this game to stream it.
Oh, add to upgrade?
Oh, oh, you see, you know the actual, the actual meta for
this game.
I know what you are.
You can upgrade it.
Now I know exactly what you are.
I need the shape.
You can use three to upgrade the rarity.
Be proud.
Stand up for what's right.
I'm playing it right now, Doki.
Well, it's already sold it.
Well, now I know how to save.
I need to get three to upgrade the rarity.
Yeah.
Okay, I think I know the angle now.
It tells you.
You guys know I can't read.
The very first illiterate VTuber.
So here.
Affelion, thank you for five gifts of ships.
Thank you.
You know by now.
Where the fuck's my mat?
Oh, whatever.
I'll come over and place it better when I'm over there.
Oh wait, there's a...
dirty card.
First J to see your collection.
Alright, you did.
You're gonna stand in the middle of it.
I don't care you don't have energy!
Put your back into it, boy!
Think about the millions and millions of dollars!
Oh, wait.
It's already full.
Whoops.
Alright.
I'm gonna buy one more to drink.
And then clean the dirty.
card.
All right, what card is this?
Oh, it's Shy Lily!
Shy Kitty!
What is that?
All right, add to...
What?
Four star rarity?
Why would you rip that?
It must have been a jealous X or some shit.
They broke up and she was like, that's it!
You can't have me!
You can't have her!
Um, it's actually um it's actually gomp gomp her famous
catchphrase gomp
yeah we'll drink one we have another card to piece together
anyway oh whoa this one's special these suck okay all right
what's so special about this one what's her name
blood cat i don't know I don't know who this one's based off
of.
Gomp gomp.
Who's Bloodray?
Bloodcat?
What's Bloodray?
Guys.
Oh, is it from a video game?
Oh, I see.
Alright, I drink another beer.
Our day at work.
Oh, backflow.
It's fine.
I'll go fix it later.
Hit the trash compactor tray from 20.
Ooh, sharps?
Wait, is it in?
Oh!
Cool, guys.
Don't look at trash.
What do you mean, washed?
It literally went in.
Oh, trick shot!
Oh, whoa!
Ow, and it's in.
Okay, I can upgrade more right now.
Alright.
uh grab this and then oh i keep i need to get speed i feel
like speed would be really good i don't think i need range
though like i'm literally standing on top of the pile and
just yoloing it oh my god i could have told my entire this i
could told my entire capcom story while i do this
i could have just done that instead it.
Okay, I drink a little beer.
Oh, hey, two dirty cards!
I'm rich.
Oh, did you guys hear about the new Yu-Gi-Oh cards?
The Crocs Yu-Gi-Oh collab?
That's going on?
Speaking of trading cards.
Oh, I can't wait to see that get scalped.
Maybe it'll just have a Yu-Gi-Oh!
True.
I know, like, Pokemon is doing, like, Pokemon Japan.
doing when we finally you notice it got announced this
morning like oh jokie bird oh my god that was like five
hours ago that might have been 20 years it literally it got
i literally saw it today in in the morning like saw the the
crock cards in the morning like
All right, we gotta drink.
You're so late.
Like, what do you mean?
It showed up on Twitter today.
How about time you noticed the story?
Oh, my God.
Might as well be 20 years too late to break this new story
to us.
Even the...
The collab cards?
Itself?
Are the collab cards also?
Like...
Oh, I didn't realize I can't collect more cards now that...
Oh my god.
Two for one.
Who's this?
Uh...
Kotmander?
I have no idea who this one is.
Is that Charmander?
Oh my god, is this Charmander?
Oh, it is!
So all burning man participants.
It's Pikachu!
Oh, I have three dirty cards.
I didn't even notice that.
But yeah, Yugio and Crocs are doing a special collaboration
for their Crocs shoes.
And I love the cards, so I love...
Oh my gosh.
Yu-Gi-Oh!
cards is wild because, like, Yu-Gi-Oh!
cards also have, like, a little story for them and
everything that comes with...
It comes with... There's, like, a little story built into
their cards, too.
If you have, like, the...
Do you have, like, the collection?
I feel like sometimes their cards feel so random, though.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, wait, there's one in the back.
How the fuck did that guy here?
let's grab more here bro am i like salvik bro i'm like
drinking all this alcohol there's another there's another
chibikota oh my blood might as well be made of alcohol who's
this one oh it's edward scissor hands it's codward hook
hands to both the enemy.
Oh, she's so clumsy.
Look at that.
She's such a dits.
Oh, it's Misa Misa!
Namine Kisu.
They select the code.
This is when I realized that Light Yagami might actually be
gay.
Have you guys seen that Twitter post where, um, okay, so,
um, Light, at one point, he's, like, surveillance.
He was being surveillance by the police.
And he was like, I'm gonna show them I'm a real teenage boy
And I'm not Kira Let me open a porn magazine Sit on my
stomach and not do anything
I'm a normal typical teenage boy
Not gay or anything And I'll throw the cops off for sure I'm
not gay Of course, me reading this porn magazines and then
not doing anything after that and also sit on my stomach
with my legs up.
Like a little, like a fucking teen, like, well, he just did,
like a teenage girl looking at fucking cosmopolitan.
Like,
oh, whoa, whoa, they won't think I'm...
They will think I'm a very normal teenage boy.
Sure.
Woo-wee.
Kicking my legs.
Look at this naked woman.
And then Misa would be like, come on, like, go to the bed.
And he's like, not now, Misa.
I gotta think about L and how to not make him think I'm
Kira.
me reject sex with the most beautiful pop idol in japan
sorry i'm too busy thinking about l and how he thinks i'm
kira i'm so busy right now that's when i realized that he
actually might be gay little model
All right.
Oh, yeah, I can piece this together now.
Silence.
Oh, there she is again.
Speaking of Misa Misa.
Pass the controller, little bro.
All right.
Nice.
Add to collection, please.
Oh, yeah.
I have all of the...
I have a lot of the poison types now.
I realize there's like It's like water Fire Poise Or is this
evil?
I guess it'd be Evil types
Light, I'm a gay Agami There he is Uh, I feel like Uh, I'll
do speed I feel like speed would be good Maybe energy too So
I can just be there Dark type Yeah, maybe Dark day oh yeah i
wanted to show you guys the the crocs let me find it real
quick the crocs uh the crocs shoes let's see it's just it's
literally called crocodile i hope yugioh fucking some an
awesome crocodile
Blending to defeat your blue eyes, white dragon.
It's only three stars.
They look nice.
I can't believe he's only three stars.
My crocodiles.
13 stripes on his belly.
13 holes on his feet.
people express themselves without hesitation.
The crocodile is said to appear with a quiet grin.
Oh my god, that's so ominous.
What?
He'll be there.
Is that the card for Pegasus?
The cross in the text box.
Wait a minute.
What is he doing there?
What do you mean by he'll be there?
I drank way too cans of beer already.
He's always there watching you.
Don't have too good of a time.
Because he'll be there.
Alright.
Got one more can in me.
He's always there watching.
I'm almost done with the first pile.
I don't even think you can complete this game today.
Oh, I'm fucked.
That should...
Why did I play this game?
Well, I told my story.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh, my God.
I was like...
Wait, what was I going to talk about?
Sorry, the story.
We'll never know.
What was Tokyo?
What was what?
Yoki!
What did you do?
I guess we'll never know.
Tell it again.
Why did I put a game in my yapping stream?
So true.
I remember if there's like anything else from the Capcom
trip.
I haven't talked about yet.
Oh wait, I have five cards.
Let me put this over there.
there you go let me uh and i'll clean the card and repair
the card real quick what's this oh wait who's this whoa wait
this is a cool card i think i got another fire i finally got
another fire type for rare cards like why are they ripping
them oh my gosh i don't know where this piece is supposed to
go.
Is this a tail?
Upward.
Where is it?
Upward down.
Alright, we'll figure that out later.
I'm actually so confused right now.
Hell coulda.
Oh, wait, she's hot.
Oh, it's hell hot!
It's hell boy!
Oh, this car, that, she's hot.
Yeah, no wonder you're so rare.
Oh, I got another air.
Is she Oh, I got... Oh, it's Morticia Adam!
The original Goff Girl.
You guys hear all the fake Goffs out there now?
They don't know the sacred text.
Ah, shit.
I forgot to...
And from the Adam's family.
You see all the discourse about, like, there was, like, a
screenshot of, like, uh, like, I don't even know, like, Some
YouTube show or whatever.
Yeah, a lot of actually larping right now.
And Goff Girl larpers.
And it was like a screenshot of these Goff Girls on like
some.
That got invited to a show.
But then they're not like.
Oh, whoops.
And then two of the girls didn't even try.
Like two of them.
Or they just like.
Wait, I like saw it.
And I was like.
At least like.
At least have black lipstick.
You know.
Like if you're gonna.
If you're gonna go to a goff YouTube show, at least put on
black lipstick.
That's the least you could do.
It's not even that expensive, too.
So I could find...
Let me do one last trash bag, and I'll show you guys.
Alright.
Oh, that one was a heavy trash bag.
the one behind just don't know my own strength you know uh i
think i can pay for their upgrades soon um maximum number
tens 20 tens i feel like i'll just screw up that
all right what almost able to unlock this oh wait i can
unlock this one oh wait never mind but let me show you the
picture right goff girls larpers oh this one holy like how
they're like holy larping okay it's not very high res photo
but you might be able to you might it's like it shows what
you need to show so you can tell like two of them didn't
really try
Like, you know, okay, I would see, like, one of them.
At least they start, like, holy larkers.
Yeah, like, like, one of them was, it's just titties.
It's just hoops.
It's not really, like, goff, you know.
Yeah, and then the other one is, like, more, like, scene-ish
and not...
Not actually, like, goff-goff?
Yeah, and then no piercings or tattoos.
Maybe it's, like, new Gen Z goff, maybe, or something.
New Age goff.
Could be.
It could be new age.
But...
I can't believe we're live in goff girls now.
Performative goff!
Who is this?
Rio Coda.
What is this?
Is this?
Oh yeah, and then...
So there's huge discourse.
I don't know who this is.
There is huge...
The non-monster girl spend all the player's money to open a
lost making eater.
I don't know which one this is based off of.
Can't tell.
And maybe I do need sensitive.
Oh my god, my sister's still stuck in there.
A lot.
But then like, I think like one of the goff girls uh, there
was like a, did a dating show with Drake or something.
Like a YouTube dating show game with Drake.
And then uh, and then Drake ended up was it he rented a
castle for her for a date now before and drake was like i
understand now yeah yeah yeah she got him he was like i get
it now i get it yeah trick drake picked it oh i need a tape
i get to listen to new music oh wait sound guy but was has a
sound okay this entire time Sorry, I was not...
I didn't know if he said anything.
Yeah, I love playing my trash cassette tapes.
As an American, very glad Drake is Canadian.
Y'all can hold that, dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
For every Ryan's we have, we can accept a Drake.
It's a necessary sacrifice.
Okay.
They gentrified golf girls.
Oh my god, what are you true?
I can't believe it.
Our golf girls got gentrified.
What's next?
It's just tiny trash left.
Or did it?
safe from gentrification oh my god snow shit
thank you thank you so much for the support snow thank you
oh my god huge shout out to snow uh hey that's snow you got
your own matisha adams wow we the sacred text all right
who's this get me.
Smokey Coda.
All attacks are reduced to one damage.
Alright, and then...
Wait, is that Ena?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm a little scared of.
Oh, I do not.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Alright, let's do the top first.
Let's...
Wow!
Alright, we're gonna...
Let's piece this in a normal way, guys.
All right.
No.
Oh, whoa.
This is, all right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Bering.
All right.
guys.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, everybody.
I got you guys.
Don't worry.
I saved the day.
The day has been saved, everybody.
You didn't want to look at it, guys.
You didn't want to look at it.
We don't want to be saved.
Don't worry.
I saved the day.
Hey guys!
I'm a hero!
Alright.
I know, guys.
It's the stream.
It's still safe for work, everybody.
You're welcome.
It's still safe for work.
We did it, guys.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot.
There was one thing I want to talk about.
So during the Capcom... Okay, so...
In Canada, the scalping in Canada is not as bad, I feel
like.
Because I'm still able to buy Pokemon card packs.
Like, I literally bought a pack at a Staples.
Because I was like, whoa, I feel like I never...
So, like, I realized it's not...
Oh, what?
Oh, oh, oh.
And...
And so I went to...
So I had to buy a charger.
charger like there was the one thing okay there was more
than one thing i also forgot to bring my jackets but another
thing i forgot was um was my charger okay we'll grab their
bag and then i'll carry more i don't think i okay i'll do
range just just for the sake of it just for fun all right
all right randomly randomly generating garbage Give me a
sec.
I'm generating garbage right now in my backyard.
Oh, hey, there's a card here.
Um, anyway, so I have to buy a charger at Target.
Because I forgot to, like I said, I forgot to bring one when
I was traveling.
And, like, I just needed a cable.
I brought the actual, like, the, the power socket.
But I forgot to bring the fucking cable.
So, I went to the Target.
to buy a cable and I there was like the Pokemon card section
I took a photo it's just god the entire row is just empty
it's crazy I it was the first time I've seen that because
like I said like it's not as bad in Canada or anything and
like also everything is locked up in Canada and and we try
to want to buy except for like I guess like staples they
have like stuff like um they do have like like for staples
for some the packs are just out there because i guess no
one's buying them but um and in some stores in canada they
have all the cards locked up so you have to go to an
attendant to like buy cards so i was like i never seen like
cards actually like um just hanging out there it's the same
cards the canadian cards are the same we don't guys we don't
have like a Canadian exclusive trading card pack, guys.
It's not like it's like the Chinese cards and the Japanese
cards.
Guys, they're the same cards.
We just...
No, they are.
We don't have a Canadian exclusive, guys.
Let me buy more beer.
Okay, I should be able to piece some cards together now.
Oh, this one's a slime, girl.
Whoa.
Jellycat.
Oh, my God.
I didn't really...
What she does.
I almost got him all.
Deep, deep dive the selected Kodama merges with Jelly
gaining her attack and XP.
Whoa.
It's very safe for work, guys.
Like, okay, I was going to show you a picture.
I can do this while I show you.
But I took a picture of it, too.
Because it's like, what the fuck?
And this just wasn't used to seeing that.
Whoops.
Alright, got my beer.
What?
A sealed Nianchi.
But could be a really cool...
Oh my god.
It's gonna be a actual non-ripped card.
Oh.
Oh my god, the quality is so new.
Oh my god.
It's PSA 5.
It's better than PSA 1.
What's this?
Smokey Coda.
Alright.
All of that.
I don't need Cheeby Coda.
Wait, I think I'm 2 now, right?
I don't know why, but I'm never associated with cleanup.
I was just imagining...
Pause the takeaway!
Container stack next to your PC.
Cotavell.
Cotavell's owner turns his gender when it's summoned on.
It's always gonna be a woman.
Let's go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cucabera.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You see, the great thing about video games is called
escapism.
Man, I sure do love escapism.
Anything from reality!
Damn, that is true.
In video games, anything is possible.
That's right, I'm cleaning in-game.
I'm doing my chores, guys.
See, I have motivation to clean here.
There's lots of motivators for me to clean up.
escaping the trash in your room by cleaning up trash in game
let's see i'm looking through my photos right now
oh bag full oh shit all right whatever it's it's fine
oh yeah oh yeah another story um so oh hey there's a dirty
car here whoops oh my god the more i clean the more the card
falls down
oh yeah so like after alcatraz
all right let me grab some alcohol real quick after alcatraz
so like everything was sort of closed by then for eating i
was like trying to find a place to eat and then okay there's
like so many the San Fran nightclub uh like there's so many
clubs and bars in San Francisco like where I was at I think
I was in downtown and like but I you know I needed food I
didn't eat you know and so there was like this place um like
I've been like I was looking at them Google Maps and then
you know there was like bars would have bar food but then
like because I was like oh It doesn't close until like an
hour and a half and I'll get there.
And it would be like, sorry, kitchen's closed and
everything.
And so I ended up like, and then one of the places, I was
like, okay, let me try this other place.
And then one of the places I went to, they were like, oh,
you can go to this place because I heard the kitchen is
still open.
And I was like, oh, sweet, all right.
And so I went over, I've walked over there and it was open.
But little do I know it was like...
I guess it was also a club because I was like I was trying
to go to the bars for like food because I was just like you
know I just wanted something to eat and so I went there and
now it's like huh this place does not feel like a restaurant
and then because you have to go to the elevator to get to
the restaurant itself um and then like and I realized like
all of ladies and not we're wearing like clubbing outfits
like very skimpy short tight dresses and then the guys are
also like wearing like you know i don't know what guys wear
when they're clubbing like he was wearing button-up shirt
and jeans and then so i was like and then i i was wearing a
t-shirt with my yellow pigment hoodie
the elevator with all these clubbers ready to party and my
yellow pigment jacket with my graphic t-shirt with my bag
filled with Pokemon and random bag charts yeah and I was
just like I don't belong here.
I was just like, I'll just order Uber Eats to my hotel room.
the stand user could be anyone.
I was like, I guess, I guess I'll just order Uber Eats to my
hotel room.
It's all right.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I felt so...
I was just like, you know what?
I'm not that hung.
I don't need it.
And then I, okay, but to be fair, for Uber Eats, I was like,
you know, there's like so many choices and stuff.
I was like, what do I eat?
Oh, so many choices.
So many possibilities.
I ended up ordering meatloaf.
I got meatloaf.
Because it's like, you can't, I, it's, I never get a chance
to ever eat meatloaf.
It's such an American food.
I was just like, ooh, meatloaf so exotic.
I was just like, oh my God, meatloaf is so...
No, it's overeats.
So exotic.
I never ever get a chance to have meatloaf.
I mean, I think meatloaf is pretty good.
Yeah, there was ketchup on it, too.
I think meatloaf is pretty good.
I never get a chance to have meatloaf.
reminds me of my first anime con after parting just to show
in some shorts i'm now upgraded to wearing a cat tail
sometimes for rays tabby thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i don't know you can't really find me look
where i live oh chef 12 cards i've been i've this is the
real game picking up trash who has time to look at cards i'm
playing the real game right now all right let's piece these
cards together i forgot the initial goal to find myself a 12
card piece
all right i know i have enough to upgrade i must have enough
for misa misa i feel like oh this is new who's here who's
she wait is this iron mouse I see, like, heart double.
Oh, it's SSSR.
Yeah, I'm Kota.
$100.
Who would rip?
That's the charm manager of Kota Mons.
I swear to God, if I'm not five stars, I'm...
If I'm not five stars, I demand to be four stars.
If I find myself, I...
again if i find out i'm under four stars i quit the game
okay wait let's see i think we have enough for musa i'm
pretty sure two inferior oh wait how do i oh even tell us
who the artist is oh that's so cool
that's right devs you i swear to god if i find my card i'm
not four and up i swear to god devs
in minecraft in minecraft of course it and then then i get
an update i'll be like guys i have to update my game real
quick a new update is available
i'll be like i love your game but it seems like i
encountered a little bug surely surely it's supposed to i
think like I get a bug in glitch where my card says it's not
four plus stars.
I know mistakes can happen.
I know.
Quick send the hot thing.
Yeah, it must be a bug, guys.
Alright, let's buy more.
Practically going to the files, changing the PNG right now.
They're changing a BNG at the moment.
I don't know.
I still haven't got my card yet.
I'm just...
Guys, it just means my card is very, very rare, right?
That's why I haven't...
Guys, it's just because my card is so super rare.
That's why I haven't got it yet.
What else could it be?
I understand, Debs.
I understand why I haven't got it yet.
I bet it's worth like, um, $80 million, too.
That's right.
Debs, this is your chance to change the God of Mon Economy
right now.
Oh, I have another card.
Oh, and another card.
Whoa.
So many cards.
No, it's like references to other...
It's like other games and VTubers.
Have I checked the car?
I've not checked the car.
Whoops.
Yeah, let me grab some alcohol, though.
What's wrong with this car?
Oh, hey.
Oh, there is a...
There is a figurine there.
yeah anime games and vtubers yeah all right who's this oh
it's another ollie
sorry kota g ola it's another ola oh he's not that bad for
this one oh it's kota go kota that's saba
and then there's another Code word, hook hands.
Time to put more trash in.
I'm a trash man.
Oh, hey, more music.
A new tape.
What tape is this one?
Oh, shit.
The sound guy told me if sound was okay.
Forgot about that part.
I was too busy picking up trash.
Let's see.
This is where fantasies become...
Playing video games is where fantasies become reality.
There's sound?
Yes, there is.
They're supposed to be.
Sound guy here?
Sound guy, how is the sound?
Did he leave?
Sound guy, come back!
Is it upgrade time?
No, I think I'll do one...
I'll do like...
Finish this set and then upgrade.
Sound is fine.
I'm always done with this pile, so it should be fine too.
Alright.
Now buy more.
Alright, and then I'll upgrade.
here uh more trash bags all right oh who's this what the
fuck is a guy in my card game oh oh bait i got baited there
we go i knew i could always count on you could have mine
oh my god it's too girls in my card game.
Severe badass.
Ascendantis.
Max 3 attacks per match.
Oh, what a plot twist.
Oh my god.
The greatest plot twist ever.
It's not a guy.
It's two girls.
Bet you didn't see that coming.
Oh my god.
Why are people throwing up hard drafts?
this could be a good for my data center did you guys see
that tweet of some guy buying thousands of macbooks for
their fucking data center and then the apple just released
um just and then the apple the next day announced the mini
mac mini macbook or whatever you guys see that that's crazy
yeah so wait let me see if i can grab the video All right,
we'll grab this pile.
We'll generate this pile.
All right, let me see if I could find it.
I know I didn't bookmark it.
I'll see if I can find it.
Macbook Data Center.
Twitter.
Let's see.
Wait, Macbook.
And everyone was clowning on him on Twitter.
it being like bro you waited one day if you if you waited
one day you could have yes absolutely here yeah and then and
then like literally apple announced macbook minis the next
day after this tweet yeah 159 gay people were like bro what
the fuck bro whoa where am i okay why
is he making a max a data center don't question the tech
bros guys do not question the tech bros they know what
they're doing
oh yes you know a lot of esport companies a lot of the newer
esport companies are just are operated by crypto bros now.
I was so, okay, so I don't know if this is true, but there
were rumors.
Okay, so if you're into, like, the rival's esports scene,
um, if you're into the rival's esports scene, there was
rumors about, like, the best DPS player for rivals in the
world was trying to get, was getting, trying to get poached
by, uh, this esports org called Swamp Gaming.
And I was just like, who is Swamp Game?
Like, I was, like, looking up Swamp Game.
And then, but the rumors was that he was getting paid.
He was going to get paid $15,000 a month.
Um, and with a 10k signing bonus.
And I don't know if this is true or not.
But, um, I have sources, not regarding Terra, but like,
Swamp Gaming paying a lot of money.
for like certain players.
I don't know if the rumors about Terra was true because that
is 15, 15, 15, 1 5k a month plus a 10k signing bonus on top
of it.
So it was like rumors about it.
And then I was like, who the fuck is running Swamp Gaming?
And like, how can, like, how can you afford this?
And then I was told they're like, oh yeah, the C.
And I was like, but they only have one team.
And it's Marvel Rivals, too.
So I was so confused.
Because I was like, oh, they must be like a super big org.
With multiple teams.
And multiple games.
But it's literally one.
It's one team.
And it's a Marvel.
It's for Marvel Rivals.
So I was just like.
I was so confused.
And then I was told.
Um.
From sources.
From like sources I trust.
Oh yeah.
The CEO is just.
Is a crypto bro.
Like.
He's just.
He's a crypto bro.
And it's like.
It's his passion.
And I realized, I don't know, okay, this is like OG
Overwatch lore.
Because he, the, um, oh, hey, Cody, delicious press fully
restores the health.
So, oh, wait, there's more.
Oh, who's this guy?
I need to use the bathroom after this.
But, and then I was looking at the Twitter, I was like,
whoa, there's so many.
The account had so many followers, too.
And I was so confused.
I was like, I was like, this is not.
the OG.
I was like, this need to have to be called something else
before because cool abs, who is Cathla, cool abs.
It's like stairs at Cathla's passes his turn, bro.
It's okay.
No one is strong enough.
I agree.
Alright, wait.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll continue the story but I need to use the bathroom.
Sorry, I forgot to uh i ran out of tissue paper to blow my
nose all right let me blow my nose real quick
all right anyway back to the story i know sorry if it's like
you guys are not into esports stuff but i thought it was
super interesting uh also jay la cone uh krish quail space
lair vincel and buy it annie solid mech meti nexi allen
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh But
basically, I was like wondering, who is Swamp Gaming?
Because I was just like, this is, it's like, they only have
one team in their esport roster.
And like, I checked, and they have like a big social media
presence.
They have like 200k followers on their Twitter account, but
they only have one team.
So I was like, and I found out they were actually, it's
Kangara or KNG.
Overwatch viewer pre-Overwatch League and everything, you
would know who Kangara, KNG is, because they were one of the
top teams back in the day before Overwatch League was a
thing.
And I was like, oh my god, wait, this was, this was Kangara?
This is KNG?
Yeah, apparently they're also like, they fielded it
apparently also had a really big uh fortnite presence
because they had they fielded several players that ended up
winning the fortnite championship so it's you know back in
the day i don't know if it still is but fortnite esports or
like fortnite esports gave you like a million dollars if you
win um like if you win uh the championship in fortnite um
but they also fielded Like, several...
Whoops.
I feel like several, like, Fortnite esports champions there,
too.
I think that's how they also made a lot of money from.
But then, yeah, I was like, oh, shit.
He's, like, OG, OG.
Yeah, I was like, if anyone remembers Michael, NYKL, he's
the CEO of Swamp Gaming.
He became a crypto bro, apparently.
That's how he got all the funds to, like, spend a lot on
swamp gaming be a lot of a little bit like some for those
for the OG Overwatch player or viewers like pre owl Kengaro
back then was like a really well known team back then like
they had like I know like like J3 used to be on KNG baby bay
if you guys remember baby bay he was what the number one
tracer player at that time and then he moved on to Valorant
and then became a world champion in Valorant and stuff so
for those who don't know why it's it's very crazy if if this
is true that uh no baby babe plays Val does he swap the
Overwatch back but I know he went back he went to Valorant
after um but like for those who don't know why it's very
crazy if Terra was offered 15k a month with a 10k bonus
signing fee.
He's a very controversial figure because he has a lot of
controversies on him and he has a lot, he's like pretty
infamous in the scene.
Before the controversies came out about the stuff, I'll
bring an example of Sinatra at his peak.
Sinatra, for those who don't know who he is, I won't talk
about the controversies about him.
But before the controversies came out about him on the drama
associated with him um he was one of the best dps players in
overwatch league to the point where in his peak like he went
on jimmy fallon basically like he um he got to be on jimmy
fallon for uh overwatch league and um him and super and he
got
believe 10k a month i think it was 10 uh 10k plus a month
during peak overwatch league back then so the fact that like
15k a month in marvel rivals is pretty insane because i
think the marvel rivals esports scene it's not to the point
uh yet maybe in the future but right now It is not Overwatch
League peak level yet.
Yeah, yeah.
So, Tanacho is only paid 10k a month in Overwatch.
And even in Valorant, he was paid 25k a month in Valorant.
But that was when he was on Sentinels.
And at that time, it was like peak Sentinels era.
Oh, yeah.
But inflation.
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, you guys see about the 2xKO?
Oh yeah, speaking of like...
I don't talk about Marvin Token, but you guys see the 2xKO.
I talked about that earlier.
But...
I feel like Rivals is very casual.
I don't think Rivals' competitive scene is there yet.
Only because the...
Oh, shit!
Whoops!
Whoops.
let me pick this up real quick um but i don't think the
rivals i think the the player base is very casual oh bro oh
my god there's a hidden trash bag over here 10 years of
development 2x ko it's very sad um 4 000 i guess i'll save
up for the bag i feel like the bag is the best investment
right now um but apparently the dev or director of why are
there like random puzzle pieces i'm hearing the fucking i'm
hearing the fucking do cars not do a puzzle is it is code
them on cars not code them on puzzles um but apparently the
director of 2xko made a statement about it and people got
really mad because in the statement he was like I'm not, I'd
rather make a interesting bad game than a boring good game.
And he was like doing this was not about the game I was
making.
It was just to learn how to make a game.
How to make a fighting game.
People got really mad about that.
Which is understandable to be fair.
You're like, what do you mean you're not here to make a good
game?
what does that mean yeah so he was like um in the in the
statement he was like um i don't regret it at all because we
think i think i made an interesting game overall but then
people were like what so you would rather the game fail but
it's interesting like i'm so you can find the state people
were so angry
10 years too he was like yeah it was like a ph i was doing a
phd on fighting games and i was here to gain knowledge glad
you had fun bro i'm sure everyone you got laid off with
undersets thank oh shiz jack sparrow they was super chat
patria said they could thank you yeah like people were like
people were so mad at that stage I'm just like, fine.
I'm pretty sure it's even worse than how I described it.
Alright, Captain J.
Koro, J.
Jokdro.
Alright, clean this card.
Oh, I can't wait to see my four-star, guys.
Because I still don't have it.
I can't wait, guys.
I bet... Oh my god.
just they made a new tier for my cards guys i can feel it i
oh whoa wait oh i leveled it up
yeah i got better rare quality i got two star instead oh
shit okay i guess it's just crumpled up how do i know if the
other cards are ready to to level up, though.
Can't tell.
The worst thing that happens that we all, yeah, that's
pretty bad.
Wait, let me see if I can find the actual quote from him.
Let's see.
I don't know if I, did I save it?
Did I bookmark it?
2xKO.
Let's see if I bookmark it.
bookmarked it.
Alright, I was primarily there to learn the how to make a
cracked fighting game part and treated my 10 years there as
the equivalent of a PhD program in fighting game development
where the game itself was less important to me than the
knowledge I unlocked from the work.
And then it's almost like Riot Games paid this guy for 10
year PhD program instead of a successful game bro what and
then right here um 10 years all right my job is to figure
out how to make an awesome fighting game making it
profitable is someone else's job i rather make an
interesting
Bro, I would rather make a fucking failure than a success.
It's not about the money.
It's the passion.
Ten years has led to this.
But to me, okay, there's no doubt in mind that we could have
made a sustainable business out of a less ambitious...
project but to me making a boring fighting game successful
would have been far more disappointing than making a failure
we were proud of it's definitely If I speak, I will get
stream chat subpoena.
Usni, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
That's actually insane.
He would, he's like, like, success, money, I would never
sell my, this passion.
I just chase your dreams.
bro Chase your fucking dreams bro fuck money
Guys who cares like i feel like if a game i aren't i feel
like if a game is Successful it can't be boring like how do
you?
i don't know Just feel like you can't really have a
successful game that's boring Like, give this man...
Make this... Promote this man as CEO!
Right now!
The wrong League of Legends is successful and boring.
Yeah, but it's not boring to them.
That's the thing.
They don't see it as boring.
Oh, hey.
Got a minute and a...
Crunch.
Another one.
Oh, Shirley.
Oh, hey.
Oh, this is a good quality, too.
Another code.
Just a...
How is it, like... What's the word?
Creast or Ready?
Like, who the fuck is holding these cards?
It's unopened.
The packages unfold, like, fold it.
Like, no scalping now.
Oh!
Yes!
Three stars!
That's a...
Oh my god!
And his four star quality!
They saw it was a Doki Bird card.
They saw it was a Doki Bird card so they were like, we can't
create...
We gotta... gotta keep that pristine PSA 9 right here.
There I am!
Oh my god.
472.20 attack.
Nice.
Plus 20 coins for every them on she defeats oh my god guys
guys guys okay i i think this is a visual bug i know it says
three stars rarity but it's an ssr oh my god it's blue dokey
it's literally just it's actually just me because i also
have the cat ears and i just have blue hair
Oh my god.
That's some quality Koda bird right there.
They made it in time.
They made it.
I gotta say.
Oh my god.
1,000.
No, no.
Y'all.
They did it.
They patched it just in time.
What if Doki was blue?
Oh my.
Of course.
Of course, it isn't in the trash, too, guys.
The shiny Doakiddy.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
There I am.
The rare Doakie missprint.
Oh, man.
Where is it?
Oh, who the fuck is, like, above me?
Who is she?
I like how I'm in the angel category too.
Told you I'm not evil.
I'm in the guys.
Look, I'm in the...
I'm technically in the angel category.
Alright, let's clean this too.
Oh, it's her.
I know I have a lot of her.
See?
I'm say so.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think I have enough for for the upgrade, right?
Oh yeah, level up.
Swap that to a level two.
Like, I don't know when I have enough for something.
It doesn't really tell you, to be fair.
Oh my god, that's actually my rarest card.
That's actually crazy.
rarest guy that I found in the cereal box.
The devs knew.
They started it.
They were like, find the seed of Doki's game right now and
put a fucking put a Doki card in the box.
It was meant to happen.
We gotta find out what file Doki's playing on.
Oh yeah, who's the artist for the Doki card?
You're right.
It is.
It's Koda.
Oh, it's the OG!
Alright, let's look her up.
Oh my god, it's Koda from Kodaman!
Yeah, I got the original artist too.
Wait, is that...
Oh my god, wait.
Moda.
I think it's all the... all the SSRs.
Yeah, oh wait, no.
That one is Koda.
Oh my god.
Koda from Kodaman?
all right who the fuck is rarer than me i need to know i
didn't know who's rarer than me
oh another dirty card
so many puzzle pieces who did not want to finish their
puzzles and then like all the puzzle pieces are the boo part
too someone like someone bought so many but oh they're evil
they're so They purposely got rid of the boob piece too, so
they'll never...
They'll never be able to complete it.
That's like edging to a whole new level.
Very angry...
Those monsters!
They threw away the boob piece!
They'll never find out what's the end of the rainbow!
Alright, we gotta Clean two cards Oh, it's her again It's
Arch Coda Also, I was distracted What was I talking before I
found Uh, Coda Bird Oh, who's that?
Oh my god I got beaten by the fucking avatar I I I The
Avatar!
Good day.
To be fair, it is the Avatar.
What does she have that?
I don't get Avatar.
I can't be angry about that.
Yeah, but the Avatar was a little bitch boy.
he ran away his entire his entire race got got eliminated he
caused the genocide of the airbenders he saved yeah after
all the airbenders died like he might he had to at this
point and you can't say that that's not an hour it worked.
Toki, he was like 12.
He can't be angry about this avatar.
He's saved, yeah, out of obligation after all the airbenders
died.
He said he was sorry, okay?
He's just a good Doki.
Maybe he didn't run away like a coward.
Yeah, and then look what happened right after.
It was Korra and then the new avatar.
Apparently the world fucking exploded after he dies.
Very sure you sell the Doki card for a hundred worth avatar
card.
Only sold for like 350 quality over quantity of stars.
Thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and then look what happened after he died.
Kora came after.
And then, you know what happened after Kora died?
The world ended.
Correction, a thousand dollars.
Lord Kora says, thank you, with a Super Chat, thank you,
thank you.
Like, Kora did her best.
That was Kora, though.
Yeah, but you know who trained Kora?
His wife!
Well, I just see two things she has that you don't.
Kora died for Avatar 3.
The Kora caused the direct end of the world.
That's right.
Technically, it's Ang's fault.
He chose to reincarnate as Korra.
Oh yeah, I need a...
What the fuck am I even supposed...
Oh yeah, I got a piece of...
I can't believe it.
I got overshadowed by the fucking avatar.
That's not how that worked.
Can't fucking believe it.
Making all these...
enemies tonight who else can I piss off oh my god I'm
missing one more this artist is pretty though well yeah but
are you drawn by the coda from codamon
is that my third I don't even know I can't tell when I have
like upgrades ready it doesn't really tell you to be fair oh
i can't i feel like i have to like look at it every time who
else but the avatar though that's the avatar fault for
choosing kora not hang zhang thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you yeah because it doesn't really tell me
kora was hot though so high did you know in the avatar
fighting game they made uh they made they uh they confirmed
azula um is gay and then because like the avatar fighting
game is based off an alternate universe um where like
everybody just knows each other in the avatar universe and
then azula is dating kora and then ozai is actually a good
guy and he's like trying to forbid kora from dating azula
because he doesn't think kora is good enough for yes i'm not
I'm not making this, I know, it sounds like fan fiction
right now.
But, like, in this alternate universe, you're so freaking
petty.
I have to thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck did I just hear?
No, it's not Katniss.
Uh, that really sounds like you made it up.
But...
Fake new...
What the hell is this cursed fanfic?
But like...
Was it not?
I saw like a clip of like...
Like a...
I saw a clip on Twitter of Osai telling Korra to back off of
Azula.
And then Korra was like...
I don't remember.
It was like...
talking about how like Azula's like her girlfriend or some
shit and then people were like can't believe they confirmed
that Azula's game through the avatar fighting game like
bro what I wasn't where is this in my place the game yeah I
saw on Twitter that's how I get all my news on Twitter don't
get us that I'm listening Azula slash Cora that I got faded
with Let me see if I can still find a tweet.
I may or may not have gotten baited.
Who knows at this point?
All right, let me see.
I can find the Twitter sources.
Oh, my God.
Wu Yang has a crush on Juno.
Whoa.
All right, let's see.
Azula.
Korra story mode fighting game I saw this like during the
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait Okay, to be fair, this is Okay,
I don't know, guys I don't know, I'm reading the lore of the
screenshot guys
but oh
my god one yes who did
and then oh there was this part too his father was right
She's a bad influence on you.
No, there's more to it.
Wait, oh, wait, look at this.
Look at this part.
Oh, wait.
Look at this.
I like this.
avatar is not fit for my little prince now this has to be
edited your ass is elucidating something by this all
alternate universe though this is all alternate universe
holy shit no way you how do I elucidate that how do I
elucidate you're this avatar is not fit for my My little
princess, what else can I imply from that?
What?
What else?
What else can I fucking like?
There's no way.
Of all the universes they could show him, he's right.
What else can I gather from the screenshot, guys?
What else?
Please tell me, someone who plays the game, has anyone
played this game and can confirm?
Because I haven't played this game, I don't know.
Does anyone play this game and can they confirm this scene
right now?
Okay, bro, that's it.
I'm booting up the game and confirming it myself.
I have it.
It's real.
Next, it's real.
I told you.
Nobody.
They booted her because she was right.
Go to the downtown.
He was talking about Zuko.
No way.
goth oh shit look at that there's the goth girl oh shit i
got another one the two for it's real she called they called
it crazy and then she pulled out the receipts never doting
toky again
they called it crazy And once, don't you really need the
avatar stream?
Anyway, I thought that was...
I thought that was wild.
They hated her for speaking the truth.
Because I guess Asami...
Because I guess Asami's isn't in the game.
So...
Do not believe her lies.
Don't worry.
Elquist is coming to report back.
Apparently this was like when she was...
Korra was still training.
So she was still like...
She was still being trained by...
And like...
By...
What's her name?
By Katara back.
So it's not when she like went to Republic City.
Before...
Asami was in the, before Mako or Asami was in the picture,
to be fair, the animation is beautiful in Korra, but the
writing is ass.
Like, I'm sorry if this is like, I know it's not
controversial opinions, but people who defend Korra, like
the Korra show, are very vocal about the Korra show.
But, like, the writing is not great.
Like, the writing is absolutely, like, like, it's just
mediocre.
But like, there are very vocal Korra fans to be like, I'm so
tired of people and shit talking to Korra show.
It's not Korra's fault that all of this was happening.
Like, she had to deal with so much.
Oh, yes, you have...
Bro, Alan's fucking entire family died.
Like, his entire culture died when he was 12 years old.
But Korra had it so hard.
yeah i love the villains in that show i just hated watching
i just hated that the entire avatar crew was just like very
merry suit gary suish and someone has to watch avatar i'll
take the fighting game lore as the truth well thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you i hate that bolin just be
like i just know how the lava bends like fucking okay like i
never trained for it he was just like i guess it was just
inside me all this stuff like, oh, what?
Like, it's just a life and death situation.
And I guess I can, I guess I'm just a prodigy at lava
bending.
Like, even when you're a prodigy, like, even when, like,
Toph was a prodigy, she still had to, like, learn how to,
like, figure it out and stuff.
Like, she had to, like, she literally had to learn how to
invent metal bending.
You just have to believe in yourself guys and then bowling
was just like i just did it it's like oh my god guys like
just i just fucking firebended all you gotta do is believe
in yourself believe also i really did not like the mako uh
sami fucking love love triangle i okay i think kora was a
very like you can be like oh she was like misunderstood
she's like a very she has many layers to her some fucking
shit but like did you really have to have mako cheat on i
mean like asami like look at her like bro i guess like it
was like asami and then or the avatar but still like kora
made mako cheat on asami just for um just for kora to like
break up with Mako and then fucking hook up with Asami.
Like, oh, yay, lesbians.
But still, that's pretty fucked.
Like...
I was like, bro, what?
If her Mako was, like, a little bit of an asshole, too.
But, like, he did not need that plotline.
She was playing the lawn game.
yeah and then she got jealous of a kid for having like
jealous of like uh what's this oh what's this oh it's this
based off of how what's it called the Cerberus game I'm
trying to remember god I'm trying to remember that game I
really I really love the art style of this game hell taker
yeah yeah yeah yeah Tensins, yeah.
They made, like, she got jealous of one Tensins' kid because
she was a prize, you have airbending.
And I'm like, it's not about you, Cora.
Like, oh my god, let her have this.
Like, oh, I'm sorry.
Like, why are you sad about, like, the child by this little
child?
child having getting attention over you i think she's just a
very poorly written character in general
juke thank you for the super chat thank you thank you good
morning jokey today's my birthday i know many told us happy
birthday this is my first birthday where mash catch you live
i just wanted to wish you all the other dragoons a wonderful
day hope you have a Great birthday, Juergen.
Thank you for hanging out with us today.
Oh my gosh.
Your first birthday here.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Juergen.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Oh my god.
I tried so hard.
It's still here.
Round two!
Twice evens.
Round two.
What a birthday.
Okay, I'm pretty sure I have three of hers, too, by the way.
Yeah, I can level up now.
Double cakes.
Oh my god.
Double the cake, guys.
Oh boy, two geeks.
So what was I talking about about Korra?
Um, oh yeah, and then like, oh, and then when I did not like
Pam, by the way, I think, oh, shit, I think Pam, oh my god,
like, because, you know, okay, so Tenza apparently used to
date, what's her name?
Um, uh, Toff's daughter, who was, like, one of the police,
uh, the police chief, uh, Kron, thank you for the five.
Give the ships they can thank you.
What's her name again?
Lin, yeah.
So Tenzin, Ang's kid, used to use to date Lin, but then he
married a non-bender, and her name is Pam.
And then, I don't even remember what exactly happened in the
scene, but like, but like, in one of the moment uh uh Kora
was asking Pam for love advice oh wait oh yeah to convince
Kora to fucking cheat on for to convince Kora to uh make
Mako cheat on Asami I remember now
and she was asking asking Pam Tenzin's wife what to do and
then Pam was like you should do it like you should become a
home wrecker like the advice was like it was like yeah i
home wrecked the relationship it it was worth it because
like he's clearly not with the right person and he was like
tennyson was dating the wrong girl but luckily like he chose
the right one in the end what the fuck like oh yeah he's
like yeah you should be a home wrecker make maka cheat on
asami listen to her heart which happens to be like a chase
after a guy that's taken
like literally listen to your heart aka yeah make him cheat
on his girl I think you should have had him like your
girlfriend.
And do it.
Yeah, I thought that was a fucking wild scene.
Yeah, and then it was wild that saw me forgive her after
that, too.
It's around in the most accurate episodes, a new spiritual
age where Korra is a crying child in the spirit world
because she acts like a spoiled child.
Also, from what I read is because the reason why the first
Avatar was like the, you know, the original Avatar series
was a lot better than Korra was because, um, who was it?
Was it one of the writers' wives?
I forgot.
I think it was like one of the writers that helped with the
series left the show or something.
Or like, not the, I don't remember.
I can think I'm confusing with Stranger Face.
I know, like, there were two writers that were a main part
of the show.
I don't know.
I think I'm getting confused with Stranger Things, but I
remember reading that it was, like, something related to two
of the writers that were very pivotal in the first original
series of Avatar.
And then they didn't come back for Korra.
And that's why Korra's writing is, like, a lot worse than
the original series.
Yeah, one of the original writers...
left before Korra, the one that made Avatar.
And then, yeah, and that's why, like, that's why it's not as
good as the original series.
So it's also similar to Stranger Things, too.
So one of the creator's wife was what, uh, let's see.
Grab more energy, and then more bugs.
Alright, we can piece some cards together.
I might as well try and finish the collection.
I don't care about the...
I just want to know what the other cards are at this point.
Alright.
Yeah, it happened with...
Whoa!
The raging flame.
What the fuck?
You're just...
You're just bonding.
B for Denjina's on the board attacks only her.
You're just bonding, guys.
There's some bonding time with the homies.
with the girlies.
You know, there was a bug on her ass and she had to help.
Just swatting the mosquito off.
I think I got...
I think I got all of Mertissia.
Yeah, I knew I had all of her.
There was a bug on her ass, guys.
She was just helping.
They're roommates.
Don't you ever help your roommate swat a mosquito off your
ass?
You know, just roommate things.
I think, yeah, I think the strongest, um, the strongest part
of Cora was Lurie the Villains.
I loved, um, Amon.
I loved the Amon character.
Like, Amon is a character.
And, um, and I thought all the villains in the last season
with the, what's his name?
The Lo- was it the Lotus?
Um, I thought they were really cool.
The character designs for them were really cool.
Yeah, Amon was really cool Until he took off his mask I was
like, put it back on!
I wish they kept him as a non-bender Amon was so peak And
then they made him a bender And then it became not peak
anymore I think if he stayed as like an actual like
non-bender That just fucking hate benders Like honestly
think Like, you know, can I just not have a villain That
just, you know, just a non-bender that just hates everything
like come on put the mask back on no one cares about your
face yeah yeah his whole like his whole thing was originally
supposed to be like non-bender and then you find out he was
actually a water bender this entire time because you feel
like it would be a non-bender because like in the original
avatar series what's her name the acrobat girl like she can
take away bending as a non-bender so you think it would like
fall upon like uh it would fall upon something like that
yeah and the scar thing it was such a you i really like the
backstory and the character development about amon and then
they revealed to them that everything was a lie and he was a
waterbender this entire time and he's just really really
good at bloodbending he was just a very gifted bloodbender
yeah ty lee yeah that's who i was talking about
yeah i feel like it was i think it's just i think the i
think they just need a better writing staff honestly that's
why i'm worried about the new avatar series i don't like how
it was like the thing about avatar that made it so
interesting and beautiful is the world building of avatar
like i i don't want to watch in their post like it like i
saw the trailer it's just all brown and deserts and dust and
like i guess like post apocalyptic world and everything i
mean yeah they're like oh kora destroyed the entire avatar
world and stuff
and i'm just like a bit sad about it because it looks like
the the world won't like i don't know it's just it doesn't
look that beautiful because i mean it's post-apocalyptic so
it's like it's sandland yeah we're back in it again it's
sandland time baby
the sandland too i'm just sad about that because like i love
the i love the environments of avatar and the world building
but like there's not really a world if it's just all sad If
it's just, if it's all just sad, where's the world?
I mean, the animation, I didn't watch the Avatar movie, the
newest Avatar movie, but it does, the animation looks
beautiful, though.
Like I said, I just wish the writing was better for the
movie, or not for the movie, for the newer shows.
Also, it must suck to not...
To, like, the only mentor you have is literally Kora who
fucking destroyed everything.
You can't ask anybody else.
Is Kora or no one else?
Oh, hey, it's another Kora kitty.
Alright, let's see.
How many cards am I missing?
Where am I missing now?
I gotta look it up.
Just wanna see who the other cats are.
Oh!
me who ripped my card up who is it how dare you i am a
collector's item all worlds eventually become mad max true
who was it oh i'm still 24 though let's go oh i didn't ever
got this one this is new
Okay.
Uh, Mercota.
Oh my god.
You can tell one boob's bigger than the other.
I have three cards I haven't cleaned yet.
They already upgraded all.
Yeah, already upgraded all Morticia Adams cards.
Man, this guy really cared for that card until the end.
Oh, she's new.
Squirt!
Oh, all right.
I hope that's the only way that happens.
Biblically accurate.
Code of the Diver.
All right.
Yeah, that's a wild name.
I need one more fire card.
It's just the commons.
I'm literally missing a common, too.
I'm missing one common.
Okay, I'm missing one common.
missing three that one common for fire one common for angel
and then one for water
oh my god we're so close
okay grab some cans uh brady thank you for super chat thank
you thank you core originally couldn't air brand because she
wasn't spiritual enough then she just got angry enough to be
able to air it guys if you just brute force it my role model
if you can't do it just keep bashing your just keep getting
angry eventually it'll work guys just keep getting angry
let's go the role model of the century sorry that was a long
tangent about core i'm just i just i love the animation.
I love the fight.
Like, it's so beautifully animated.
Uh...
How am I gas- Y'all explain, Elquist?
We saw the screenshot.
You gotta explain how I'm gaslighting.
Elquist, you're- Maybe you're in denial.
We all saw the screenshots.
Explained.
Was the text context?
Fake news.
I think that's fake news.
We also did a little research.
But we have no context for them.
They were just very good friends.
It could be worse like the Clone Wars TV show where you need
a Wikipedia to watch episodes and chronological or hit it.
Oh, man, Sharko, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank
you, thank you.
Zelle, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you.
Gora managed to Air Ben from being angry, which is the
opposite of Air Ben.
Ending philosophy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
And your...
And your reasoning was that there's just really good
roommates, isn't it?
Yeah.
How do we know that dragon isn't gaslighting us?
Oh, my God.
They were really good friends.
Yeah.
I don't need more buzz for this
Come on, you already explained Elquist
Explain I don't need more buzz
I'm looking
I just need three more cards to complete my collection
Are there any more cards?
Oh, there's another cassette tape.
Uh.
Ooh.
Ye-ha.
Is this new?
No, this is old.
I already have this one.
At least we have new music.
Oh my gosh.
I literally just need...
I need like...
Wait, I'm almost done with my piles.
Wait, one.
Wait, I have three piles.
Wait, I'm almost done with this game.
Wait a minute.
Do you see the vision?
Ni hao, ni tap.
Oh, yeah, I was gonna say.
Stranger Things had that same issue where the reason why the
newer seasons suck.
Um, it's because, uh, the, one of the writers, one of the
creators, uh, wife used to help with, uh, with polishing the
scripts and stuff, and then they got divorced in the middle
of the show.
So after they got divorced, like, she wasn't working on the
show anymore, obviously, because it's like, like, she's
like, fuck, we're not together anymore.
Like, hey, and that's why the writing got progressively
worse and worse.
She just, you know, she's not part of the relationship
anymore.
Was it the same with the boys?
I don't know about the boys.
Yeah, it's the wife debuff.
It was either she was really helpful, or it was the
depression divorce.
There was just one shorter butt.
It lasted, like, less than 10 seconds, and people instantly
noticed it was bullshit.
Also, I checked interaction on YouTube I want it.
Alright.
Alright, it's time.
But you gotta look at it.
It's our turn to research.
There's no way people would make stuff up on the internet.
What are you trying to say?
People would just make it up on, make up lies on the
internet?
That's it.
Alright.
Korra and Azula.
All right.
All
right, let me blow my nose real quick.
Never.
Especially on Twitter.com.
What do you mean?
I literally see.
I literally see the shorts of the screenshots we had.
That I showed.
I see I see I literally see the shorts It's implied I
literally This is real It's I saw this In the video I Oh so
now Oh, it's implied.
Implied, where's the voice?
Do they even talk in this game?
Let me check.
Oh, they do.
Alright, let's see.
Korra and Ozyme Interaction.
Demozyme is ripped.
All right, let's see.
How the fuck do I find this?
He didn't say princess.
All right, let's see.
Where's the story mode?
Okay, Korra.
Story mode.
Avatar.
What's this called?
What's this?
fighting game called i guys what's the fighting game called
again
because it's in the story mode right
avatar legends okay it's avatar legends oh my god you have
to like give me a sec let me look through this thing
apparently it's like in story mode something because it's
like what if everybody just interact was just in the same
universe guys I'm looking through the story right now guys
I'm trying my best to look through the story right now when
does Kora meet Azuya oh right here wait it's literally right
here
wait oh my God got you the timestamp 14 minutes and 1419 14
minutes and 19 that's where the dialogue came from 1419
check me it's true show the clips I browsed through the
entire fucking...
It is that fast.
Azula says to Sakura, I want what I've always wanted.
What we've always dreamed of.
The two of us was the timestamp.
Holy crap, it's real.
I did!
I waited, it's real!
I told you!
I'm that petty.
I'm that fucking petty.
I will prove you wrong.
Wait, this is scary.
That's right.
Never tell me again.
Unless she was right all along.
Omar.
Give me the time step.
Okay, chat.
I knew it.
I I hate playing the story mode.
It's 3 a.m.
Little day we're roommates.
I knew it.
You can't gaslight me.
I'm the gaslighter.
It's real all-out donkeys, bird.
Queen of the enemies, the lovers.
Yuri crash ship I fucking knew it.
I knew I wasn't delusional
Who's the real larp for now?
Still me cuz I haven't played the game.
I didn't I KOMED through the story mode to find this I knew
I was right do it
I can't believe this that's right don't mess with me when it
comes to chips I know what's technically not canon because
it's alternate universe but the fact that it implies that
Zula is is gay is pretty And if they did it in the fucking
fighting game, it's pretty funny.
Oh my god, I have like an entire stock.
And that's where all my money went.
That's where my money went.
I was molded by it.
I was there during peak tumblr.
Don't mess with me.
I told you it was real you all laughed you all booed her cuz
she was right you got her delusional now look who's the Lulu
it could be canon if Azula and Kora were there at the same
time it could have happened they were both just born in the
wrong time at the wrong place maybe that's why Zula was so
evil she was just in the closet
she was just a repressed lesbian that's why she was so evil
and it's not that I didn't believe it's I didn't want to
believe it was real Revelling at your leaf truth.
Kora and Azula could have fixed each other.
It's...
I think it fixed each other, guys.
It all makes sense now.
She's not evil.
She was...
No, it's because she was...
She was repressed.
Maybe she had a crush on Ty Lee.
and the other, I forgot the other girl's name to be fair,
I'm sorry.
And then, and then she was so mad that they ditched her for
men.
And that's why she was so evil.
She thought she was gonna have her lesbian, lesbian girls'
trip, her lesbian fantasies, but then her best friends
turned out to be straight.
And then, and then that was like the final straw.
Chat, this all started because the avatar What up, Toki?
Thank you for the super chat, Sal.
Thank you, thank you.
Dude, her dreams of a thruple.
The lesbian.
I'm just thinking about the lesbian movie.
You guys hear about the lesbian, lesbian, lesbian.
She didn't have her lesbian fantasies come true.
Do you guys hear about the, what was it called, the lesbian
alien movie?
That was made in New Zealand, right?
Is the production company New Zealand or Australian?
Yes, the lesbian space princess movie that was supposed to
come out on September 11th.
Wild date to pick from, by the way.
But it was a movie called Lesbian Space Princess, but that
was supposed to come out on...
September 11th on 9-11 and uh and it was the whole move it's
an animated movie about lesbian princess and about lesbians
and then the best part about the movie was the white what is
it called the white straight millions the only lesbian space
movie I need is cosmic princess kaguya thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um so so it was the white
space wait white straight millions and they were uh no tall
white space male aliens and apparently had the best lines in
the entire movie um that was all about that was supposed
about lesbian space princess let
me see i could find a scene from that movie some i thought
okay i thought the i because of the voice actors they got
for the white space millions uh sorry white straight
millions were like uh i would like their it was a what was
it called they were comedy trope but and they were like one
of my favorite comedy groups because they have they had a
show money and i'm trying to remember oh my god just need
all the cards i'm still missing i'm just missing one from
the angel one from the fire and then three from the demon
pack
auntie donna yes i love auntie donna they're so funny i love
their um i love their netflix special at like netflix show
and i don't know if they they have a really good netflix
show
um auntie donna's big old house of fun so they got these
guys the voice act the white space on the internet white
straight millions every time i say it i feel like i feel
like i shouldn't say it because i'm just like who white
straight millions because it's so it's such a fucking weird
movie this I could find the clip of it I don't know if I
bookmarked it at all I think like I could just find if I
just search it up the straight part is so important in the
end they end up becoming a thrupper they got thick they were
able to achieve what what azula could never have they're
like wait a minute guys why are we always trying to find a
woman in our lives when we have each other maybe we don't
need a hot hot female in the maybe we can just we maybe
Maybe we should just have each other.
Maybe we should watch that in member stream.
What do we do?
It was like a lesbian, a space, a princess.
Let me see if I can find it.
I'm gonna try to find that exact clip.
Because I think that clip was pretty funny.
So it's like as a lesbian, this turned me straight.
all right let's see i'm trying to find all right what is it
called uh i'm trying to find like what the the okay there
you go straight white millions i'm thinking wild
all right here we go
all right here's like one of the scenes oh yeah i forgot
about that part duck thank you for the super chat thing
thank you forgot the part where the princess is from the
planet clitopolis clitopolis and it was kidnapped by the
straight white millions to power their device oh yeah the
device would help them find hot chicks
Alright, there's another clip, by the way.
That cannot be real.
It was real.
It was absolutely real.
Alright, back to cleaning cards.
Yeah, they were trying to build a chick magnet.
It could only be...
And it could only be powered by lesbians.
I think it's the most I've ever talked about lesbians, guys.
I'm Sometimes wonder why you don't so...
Oh, hey!
Hey, Silent.
So, this is what I've been doing instead of work stuff, I
guess.
I know nothing about Steinscape.
I know a lot about lesbian space princess.
From everything that was on my Twitter today.
Whoops.
Yeah.
Oh, that's going far.
I was not hitting that shot.
What is this dialogue?
I can't play on stream.
I'm worried that the...
I'm worried that the lesbian space princesses are gonna get
me.
Count, today's a good day for me, guys.
I didn't... I knew I would.
I proved the point.
Alright.
This is a good day.
I won.
I just need like.
I need like.
What?
I still haven't found these.
I literally need one, two, three, four, five.
Six cards left to complete my collection.
Oh yeah.
It all started because of the.
Because of fucking.
Dang.
Can't believe it.
I got beat by the fucking avatar.
He's not even alive anymore.
He's fucking dead.
We're two generations past the avatar.
Move on.
How am I missing the commons?
Such bullshit.
Oh no, we're looping now.
We're back.
Yeah, until he...
Until he turned 15.
And then we...
Someone didn't watch the Avatar movie.
Fucking doesn't want to kill.
Let's all these mass murderers just walk around.
Not so good
If he was so good Why can't he kill for the sake of the
world?
For the greater good Sounds like Fat Man In fact this film
got 600k Grand from the South Australian Film Corporation
Which is government also is posthumously Taxed taxpayer
funded 600k oh my god bro give me 600k i'll make a i'll make
the sequel i'll make the sequel
that's crazy taxpayer funded lesbians
i literally am just missing the common cards like who are
they i got the rares too there should be a way to be faster
at like grabbing cards too
do they grabbing the cards is like grabbing the garbage is
really slow
okay got that beer in me that should i'm gonna grab two more
cards and then i can at least construct two card three cards
come on oh my god this has to be the oh my god i'm like i'm
like two junk piles away oh because one of them is the rare
one million card i forgot about that one of them is the rare
ass card too that's why oh i'm never gonna complete i just
actually complete the game to complete the collection as an
aussie i approve giving jokies 600k to make a lesbian movie
Alright, let's see.
New letter bag.
And then...
Oh, wait, there is speed.
Whoops.
Maybe I should have done that first.
I was like, I should have been speed and putting garbage in
my garbage.
There was.
Lil Didokino.
And she just never bought it.
Cucabera, thank you for Super Chat, thank you Thank you.
I'm holding it.
Oh my god, so much faster.
That one upgrade is actually a lot faster.
Not gonna lie.
We're gonna have more.
We just need...
Actually, we can grab...
I can grab one bag.
I should be able to make enough for...
Should be enough, actually.
Just do that and then make a card.
Fuck it.
Let's do distracted.
You're right.
yeah how much was it 2,250 god damn it all right let's make
the cards oh i already got this one
yeah all right nice oh my god i got all of these already
where are the commons what are those cards called in pokemon
where they're like um
Oh, bunk.
Where are my bulk cards?
Excuse me.
This should be like three cents or something.
I should be able to go to the store and grab them.
Why am I collecting it from the trash?
I should be able to buy like a hundred of them for like one
dollar.
My fucking bulk cards.
Okay.
Another Chibikoda.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure I can level her up.
I remember she was like...
I had three of those.
Alright.
Back at it again.
They're out of print, dokey.
Where's my PSA 0?
The fact I can PSA anything.
anymore is actually pretty crazy like what fuck PSAs there
was like what was the craziest one not the manga uh there
was a wild PSA that they did because I'm like how how do you
even compare how do you even like grade that like yeah I
know PSA is sort of a it's not sort of it is scam what's the
other one I was watching videos of it too like there's
another one that's not PSA?
Uh.
Our speed.
There was another one.
That wasn't PSA.
It was.
That everyone else used this too.
Newer grading system.
If Pokemon Real, do you think scalpers were spam-cached
Pokemon to sell?
I feel like...
I feel like we would be eating them.
What?
I feel like...
I feel like we'll be eating a lot of the...
Oh, tag, yeah.
But I heard tag is like AI assisted too.
And sometimes the AI is wrong.
Yeah, I was thinking about tag.
I feel like...
I feel like we'll have like...
What are they called?
Like the meat farms?
Oh, there's like a specific word for them.
Slaughter houses?
I feel like we'll have Oh puppy mills We'll have Pokemon
mills For sure If they were real Bro Surprisingly for the
Pokemon universe With all these giant Pokemons and
everything I'm surprised there's not a lot of wars I'm
surprised that I don't know.
The regions don't go to war with each other.
That's just how it works.
Yeah, Pokemon buy a weapon.
I mean, like, more, though, you know?
I'm surprised there's not more wars than we see.
It's more so that...
you think, like, which Pokemon were you sending to war?
Yeah, but they, like, moved away from the military stuff,
though.
Yeah, I mean, Mewtwo.
Oh, you're right.
Mewtwo was a bio-weapon.
That's so true.
I almost forgot about that.
He was.
But the...
The anime sanitized a lot about Pokemon lore.
You have to read the Pokemon Yellow comics for like the
actual Goren shit with the actual like Pokemon murders.
No, that's not true.
If you ever read Pokemon Yellow, that's where the hardcore
shit is.
Yeah, I mean you can literally just use Earthquake.
Like, like the implications of Pokemon, you know?
Like, you can literally get a whale lord and just fucking
send it out to like like are there like anti-pokemon
defenses for this yeah like
there's clearly like the implications of self-destruct and
earthquake
yeah but you ever read the pokemon manga is like pokemon
like pokemon is it pokemon adventures
show like yeah they saw there's an art book that gets sliced
in half and also like actual food made out of Pokemon in
there there's
actual that there was also like a lewd Pokemon manga too
that my my parents bought me I don't think they realized it
was a I remember owning it and I was just like I was like
huh I was like a little kid.
I don't remember if anyone remembers that particular manga.
Um, I know it got heavily censored in the English uh, in the
English version of it where like, uh, Ash would be like
peaking at Ash and Brock were peaking at girls at the Hot
Springs and everything.
Does anyone remember that manga?
I have the official, I have the official version of it.
I don't know, I think I have the, I don't know about the
English version or the Chinese version.
Okay.
Because I think, like, my parents thought...
Because it was like, it's a Pokemon comic book for her, you
know?
Oh, yeah, the electric tail, the Pikachu.
I can't show it on stream.
Wait, actually, let me see if I can find a safer work image.
The electric tail.
I have the physical copy of this.
Let's see.
uh i think it was like the hot springs that's one way to
teach your kids about the fidgies and the beiges thank you
with a super chat thank you thank you
all right let's see so there was apparently this in this
uncensored version it was basically like misty in the hot
springs you
say i can find the censored version
Let me see if I can find the censored version of it.
Oh, my God.
They took the M-Gurlink down.
Coward.
I'm trying to find it, guys.
I'm not having much luck.
Neck, trick, tail.
There's no one owned this anymore.
It's basically super duper fan service-y.
It's like...
The artwork is really beautiful.
There was just a lot of very fat...
Like some of the scenes were like...
Oh yeah, so here.
So this is one of the fan service...
Like...
It's just a very fan service-y manga and I owned it as a
kid.
Because my parents are like, Pokemon.
Because I like Pokemon.
Oh.
And I remember this manga.
Yeah, I had it, too.
Oh, Jesus.
So, so I own...
I think I don't know how many volumes I have of...
I think I have all the volumes of it, I'm pretty sure.
That was a little kid.
Oh, was it drawn by Dogein' Art?
Back in the day of Pokemon.
Did not care that much.
of
back in the day and it was the wild wild west when they
haven't established their identity yet for being kid
friendly the sacred text yeah I get more beer bro I swear
I'm still fucking oh my god I'm still fucking collecting for
the two cards.
I have all of these!
How many cards can there be?
I'm getting fucked by RNG right now.
The only way to teach you...
Oh yeah, oh yeah, that's right.
Reading this manga Young Age probably explains a lot about
you, affectionate.
That I grew up to be completely normal.
Okay.
Just like you and I.
Just like all of you guys.
Very normal childhood.
That reminds me of being like 10 and reading Dragon Ball
Steam Blum Machine.
And you know you know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, another clean card.
Where are the cereal boxes anyway?
There was no cereal boxes in this one.
another card piece
I'll drink another beer I've drank 146 cans of beers now oh
hey nice I mean I have like two piles well technically three
I guess
oh nice got another one oh my god I've been fucking picking
up trash for three hours
I just want to know I just want to know what the Other cards
are...
I wonder if it's RNG.
Or if it's scripted.
Does anyone know if the card collecting is scripted or RNG?
It's like...
I assume like when I'm done with this pal, it's over.
Eh.
There's no way.
And there's no way there's more trash.
I'm gonna actually put this away.
Eh.
all right then i should have enough to buy more speed and i
can clean five cards oh my god is this new oh my god this is
oh no it's hell boy it's hell coda oh this okay i already
have that joki's mom has never seen your cleaning so
diligently thank you for the super chat love Good
comparison.
It's okay.
I still have tomorrow before dad comes home, guys.
I still have tomorrow.
There's still time.
Don't worry.
I'll definitely clean this time.
Oh my god.
I have all these cards.
I literally just need a common.
There's no way there's more trash.
Where else could the trash go?
Oh my god, I just unlocked this too.
Oh, okay.
I know I have...
Okay, I can level this one up.
Who else?
Okay, I level this one.
Oh.
Okay, thank God I can skip up the...
I can skip the...
Oh, wait, never mind.
I can skip the cutscene a little bit.
Oh, okay.
Oh, and I can swap this.
Ooh!
Alright, that's me.
Wait, is that?
Wait, I only two.
Alright.
I need two of that.
One more of that.
And then...
And that's all of them.
My collection is almost complete.
Surely the trash can go faster.
And they keep upgrading.
I don't know if I should just keep upgrading speed.
I think speed's the key right now.
Oh my god, we're almost done.
We're so close.
Okay.
Oh, another card.
That card to clean.
They clear.
Okay, these guys are not separating their trash properly.
Why would you put the cans with the compost and the GPUs
with the cans?
You not know how to recycle?
Recycle, reduce.
reuse oh my they are not using their bins correctly this is
the city dump um why are the fruits mixed in with the glass
cans and the oh germany's not gonna like this that's a fine
if this wasn't germany right now so many people are gonna
get fine oh the europeans not european union's not gonna
like this
welcome to America think of all the mud oh my gosh okay this
okay I don't know you guys have you guys ever he's been like
terrorizing my shorts algorithm but there's this guy who's
like his entire identity is about doing stuff on a budget
but it's like pretty gross at like at some point so like
he's like I don't remember call he's like something on a
budget and his fans are called budget baddies and um his
whole identity is just doing everything on a budget and like
no matter what like i'm pretty sure it's like he has some
actual like he's has trauma associated with because of like
student debt and also growing up poor and um and then no
he's like american and he like goes dumpster diving for for
toilet paper um Because he thinks it saves money.
And it's like...
But I'm like, pro.
Like...
Toilet.
Like he...
Yeah.
So...
He's like purpose- But the thing is, his YouTube channel...
His TikTok slash YouTube channel is like...
So successful that he doesn't have to...
He can actually buy toilet...
Oh, so he sleeps on a campus bed.
And...
Um...
Every time he travels...
He only eats chicken...
and scrambled eggs.
I swear to God, I've never, because I got curious and I
want, like his shorts sometimes shows up whenever I'm like
scrolling through YouTube shorts.
And I've seen some of his videos.
And all he, and he went to, he had like college debt.
He went to culinary school.
And I was like, bro, you went to culinary school.
And by the way, he uses his hands to spread the oil on his
pan and everything too.
But yeah, like uh and he hits the towels he uses a towel
rack where he staples like a bunch of towels together to
make into a big towel and but all he eats is scrabble eggs
and chicken um every day and he unplugs his fridge whenever
he travels but i'm like doesn't that end up using more
energy because Like your power into your fridge every time
you plug it back in and everything.
Um, but yeah, it was so sad.
Because I think it was just, it was literally just trauma.
Like, I think he's just like trauma bonded with budgeting at
that point.
Like at that point, that's like, it's like a strange, it's
like an addiction at that point.
And, um, but yeah, no, he like dumpster dives for, uh, for
toilet paper.
And I'm like, bro, like.
That's not hygienic, oh my, bro, like, yeah, you can do
stuff on, but that's not hygienic, bro.
Like, oh my god.
That's, that's actually crazy.
Like, you're using toilet, like, dumpster toilet paper and
napkins.
It doesn't matter if you fucking spray it, sanitize, like,
spray, like, what's it called, sanitizer on it.
Like, yeah.
It was in the dumpster.
It's literally in the trash can.
Like, that's just too much, bro.
Punch is pretty tight.
Oh, my God.
And please tell me it's the card I need.
I always see her.
My ass can never look away.
Yeah, it's like something on a budget.
I don't remember his full name.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, she's new!
She's new!
I've never seen her before.
Wait, wait.
She's actually new.
Use a plant at that point.
Old Men's Sharko.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
And he, like...
He uses a water filter that he, I don't know if he's still,
that he hasn't like, clean, like, that had mold growing on
it.
And I was like, bro, like, bro, okay, I've done some fucked
up shit, but, like, bro, change your water filter.
If your water filter has mold growing on it, please change
your water filter.
Let's see.
doesn't shower like he like he no he does shower but he like
he like he would just like if he doesn't have to shower he
would just wash his head wash his hair like in the sink
like i'm like oh my god like bro like yes budgeting is fine
but
Wait, let me see if I can find...
I need to check the video.
Like, because he was like, oh my god, like, let me see if I
can find the video where it made me go, what the fuck?
Like...
Let me see.
Alright.
Budget guy.
I'm just gonna look up...
Okay, here we go.
I have to, I have to...
Okay, Bradley on a budget.
Yeah, that's the guy.
That's it.
This guy apparently has, like, a million followers on
TikTok.
He just recently started uploading stuff on YouTube, so
that's why, like, yeah, he has a million followers.
This guy has a million followers on TikTok.
And he still lives like this, and I'm like, I'm like, oh my
god, bro, bro, you don't have, like, I get it.
It's content now, but, but, you don't have to do this to
yourself.
All right, let's see.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Okay, so one of the things he does, he doesn't buy a phone
screen protector.
He uses tape on his phone because he's like, he would just,
he would just like, uh re like he would just like retap it
every couple of months and I'm like oh my god are you oh my
I'm just
I it's so hard to like process everything
I I I don't know.
I just feel like it won't observe any impact, though.
Like, I don't think that's protecting anything.
I was like, yeah, you can be on a budget, but, like, you
just need to buy one screen protector.
That's it.
You just need to buy one screen protector.
But yeah, that's, like, the videos that comes up on my...
on my YouTube shorts.
This is crazy.
I feel like he would be...
I feel like if you, like, add on, like, build on top of it.
Like, over time, you'd be spending more on tape than the
screen protector.
Because you just need to buy one tape.
Like, sorry, one screen protector, you know?
And that's it.
You're just set.
Yeah.
And then, yeah, he used weeds as his pot of plants.
okay the dumpster diving for a toilet paper is what's what
is where i draw the line i don't care about how much
disinfectant you're using uh oh yeah i think he used dish
soap for a laundry detergent too i was just like i i i feel
like it doesn't matter how much disinfectant you're using
like bro buy a new towel please for the love of god if you
look at his comments is everybody telling him to please for
the love of god buy a new towel and towels are five dollars
for the love of god buy a new towel and you look at his if
you look at his comments and it's literally everyone's just
like please buy a new towel please please buy a new towel
and we were like this has to be rage bait holy shit i feel
like i'm getting rage baited right now that towel is on life
support
i need 6 000.
he's not that's the that's the worst part he's not rage
baiting He's selling this as facts of life.
That's the thing.
That's, it's not rage bait.
Why is he posting it online?
Bro has 1.7 million followers on TikTok.
I don't know, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is this what the youth call finance for us?
Oh, man, Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this point, it had a better quality of life as the Amish.
I'm just worried for his fucking health.
He also doesn't have insurance.
I mean, I don't have...
Don't learn from me.
Oh, I have new music.
No, but he doesn't get...
insurance for like um for like stuff he does like if he's
like renting a car or some shit doesn't get away there was a
uh cat yeah but to be fair i am canadian to be fair to be
fair guys i do have the canadian uh the canadian buff where
we still have to wait five to eight months to But with our
free healthcare.
That's right, guys.
I get to wait five to eight months to see a doctor with my
free healthcare.
Okay.
Here's the figure.
Nice.
This is cool figurine.
Surely, I swear to God, I haven't found a new card in like
80 years.
Let's get these two genies that were our roommates my genie
roommates all
right next card oh my god the goddamn avatar
all right let's see oh this one again
let's see the commas are so fucking rare it's actually so
tilting
like I'm getting every other commons but this the two ones I
need for my collection
like I haven't seen a single golf mommy yet in like 20 years
all right give me the next trash all
right next pile
okay surely it's oh wait it's the last one wait this is the
last one wait Wait, I think it's over.
Wait, this is the last one.
Surely it's in here.
It has to be.
I'm digging through the trash for the gold now.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
It has to be in here.
Where else could it be?
We've reached the last pile.
They can't hide any more cards.
Oh, whoops.
I dragged there.
Let's drink that.
I can increase my speed here, too, later.
Come on.
Keep pocketing.
Keep pocketing!
I'm in it!
I'm in the deep end now!
Where's the trash bag?
Is there one more that I chucked and then fucked up?
Where the fuck was that other child?
Oh, there it is.
I'm gonna find this one.
Okay, I should be able to upgrade the speed again.
Alright, do speed, and then...
Then we'll do try and save up her bag.
I don't think I need range.
I'm literally, like, in the depths of this trash.
I'm, like, inside it right now.
I don't think I need speed.
I just... I mean, I don't think I need range.
Like, I'm inside him.
Oh shit, I forgot to buy more alcohol.
Yeah, I forgot about the energy.
Could buy more...
Okay, 660.
I need more capacity.
I could buy more alcohol.
Just to min-max it.
Wait, these are unopened Oreo boxes.
What the fuck is having a party and not inviting me?
trash nest too yeah see if i was a budget baddie i would
take those plates and just wash it but he did get good
advice at some points like he was like dumpster diving
during if you're like if you're actually like you know on a
budget or uh you're like uh you know just needing extra hand
um the helper and stuff um he he did like dumpster diving
during graduation that's smart That's actually really smart.
But, like, I wouldn't look in the garbage bag.
I think that's the gross part.
Like, bro, you're, like, university students are fucking
disgusting.
They do not, they do not separate their trash at all.
As a university student, I put everything in one trash bag.
I did not care.
I, but you can look for furniture, like, beside the trash,
like, dumpsters, you know?
Like, that's smart.
You know, if you're looking for, like, Furniture and stuff.
Dumpster diving drink.
Yes, he opens the trash bags, guys.
Like, some of the fucking paper, like, toilet paper and
stuff he finds are in the trash bags.
Like, I feel like that's smart.
Like, dumpster diving for furniture?
Yes, that's smart.
But not fucking opening the trash bag themselves.
Because I guess, like, like, a universe.
Oh, we did not care about separating anything.
Okay, gotta throw this in there.
Alright, let's buy another capacity too.
Just for the sake of holding one extra more beer.
How much is it?
It's $30.
Alright.
This piece, oh my god.
It's more of the same goth.
Mommy.
There's a beer.
Everything in this game is inflated.
Everything.
That's going to be a...
It's just hot.
It's the future.
Guys.
It's just 2030.
See you all in 2030.
When beer is 30 plus now.
Yeah!
You know what?
At least I get to see myself.
Shiny dokey bird.
Yeah.
That's me!
I think I have a right...
No, I think I need one more.
Oh my god, this is fucking jellycat.
I swear to God.
It's...
Oh shit, now I have to fucking do this again.
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry, it needs a lot of concentration.
Ah!
Back into the pile.
My little nest that I made.
Wait, let me double check something.
Uh...
Yeah, blue dokey.
Not to be confused with yellow dokey.
Okay, let me check something real quick.
Alright, back to trash collecting, guys.
Here I go.
That's what I'm saying.
This was trash.
Germany.
There's going to be so many fines right now.
I've been working all day.
My sister's still not here.
Guys, I think there... Guys, I'm starting to think there
might be more trash coming in later.
I'm starting...
I'm starting to feel like more trash is coming.
This might not be the last pile.
Okay.
I'm really not.
I know I'm getting a little concerned, guys.
That this might not be the end.
My suffering has only begun.
There's no way.
Surely that Crypto Bro was going to find us USB, right?
Just like when the Crypto Bro lost millions of dollars.
when he actually threw away his USB that had his crypto
wallet.
He was successful, right, guys?
Right?
He found this USB, right?
After five plus years of searching, he did it.
I didn't read the end of the article, but I assume he was
able to find the USB.
holy shit what okay wait do you okay thank you super chat
thank you thank you when i was a student i found like three
oh my god that's crazy that's what i'm saying it's like i
feel like i think it's smart to dumpster dive like during
graduation or like moving out periods because like you know
Like I said, like a lot of students
They you know, they don't want to move their furniture like
they don't the furniture is not there forever So they're
just like so they just So they just dump it Because there is
just like dorm furniture for them.
So like that's smart But don't fucking grab it from like the
actual trash bag and stuff.
It's it's disgusting like students are teenagers are, and
young adults are very, very not separated.
I don't even know what, they're just gross.
As an ex-university student, we were gross.
We didn't care.
We had to study or party.
I don't know, one or the other.
We had other things to worry about instead of separating
trash.
Also, speaking of that, Juge, did you guys see the panty and
stalking Tenga?
I was just like, what's a biblically accurate fleshlight?
So, Pandian Stocking did a collab with Tenga.
And there was a tweet.
Wait, let me show you guys the tweet.
It's so funny.
And people were like, it's like, it's just like, what the
fuck is that?
Okay.
I'll fly away, fly away.
I know I bookmarked it because I wanted to talk about it on
stream.
All right, let me see.
Let me find my bookmark.
Um, okay.
Is this?
Oh, here you go.
Can I show this on stream?
Yeah, I can.
It's almost like biblically accurate.
And then people were like, I love this comment.
this but what the fuck does that even feel like bro what is
that there's a wheel inside it too so I was like why the
fuck does it have a wheel inside it what do you
oh my god do I get it where did I go so it's the Um, it's
the Pantheon Stocking Collaboration.
What is that?
Yeah, it's like, what does the wheel even, what is the wheel
even for?
Are you sick wheelies on the pee-pee?
Sick wheelie, bro.
It's the secret.
I gotta steer it.
The pen's so sharp in there.
I don't think you would want to stick that in.
It's like the spring log.
It's an anotronic.
Hoor, hoor, hoor, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho,
ho.
And let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, that popped up on my timeline.
That's doing a crazy sound on the whip, bro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see what...
I don't think I can afford anything.
I'm going to buy more in beer.
I need to hydrate.
Stay hydrated, guys.
Alright, time.
God damn it.
I haven't seen a new card in so...
a lot.
This is the worst part.
My RNG right now is so bad.
At this point, I'll just buy it.
I think it'd be easier if I just buy the cards.
I just buy more cereal boxes.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Oh my god, there is.
That's a new one.
That's a new cat!
Oh my god, it's Amori!
This is Kuro Nekomari.
Kodama, she touches just dies.
She just fucking dies.
Wait, I think this is also new.
Wait, have I got...
Oh, wait, no, I got Blood Cat.
Yeah, I finally saw something new for once.
Yeah.
I didn't think that was possible.
Whoops.
roots.
I was gonna say it.
It looks so weird.
Wait, wait, she's new!
Double may cry, cat!
Ha ha!
I knew it!
All the other cats were just endgame cats!
Alright.
We're on endgame now, KMC!
Oh my god, cat may cry!
Okay, how many more do I need?
Okay, I need two more.
I need a super rare and then okay I come oh my god I'm
actually completed I completed this and then I literally oh
my god wait wait I could what oh I completed this I forgot
but coca I don't know who this one is who is that I have no
idea who this one is but oh my god I need one I need three
more cards yes I'm still going I gotta complete my
collection My collection needs to be completed.
I just need three more cards.
We're almost there.
We're gonna see the finish line.
Let's keep on collecting.
Keep on collecting.
Social media is really getting young people unrealistic.
Standard.
Shake my head.
Juge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can see the end.
I can actually see it.
Drink that beer!
Damn, I must be like...
I must be from the salvage or something.
I think I drank almost 200 cans of beer.
And I'm still going on strong without water.
This is my water at this point.
Oh, did you guys see that Valve got hit a 30th anniversary?
And then said nothing about it?
It's just...
It's just another day at Valve HQ.
Yeah, they just can't count.
It's just the number started with a three.
They can't acknowledge it.
Yes, yeah.
They were just, everyone else was like, Congratulations,
Valve, on your 30th anniversary.
And then silence.
Nothing to report.
I hate just doing it, we're just like, oh well.
Gabe looks good though.
He had a public appearance recently too.
He definitely lost a lot of weight.
Wow, there's so many dirty cards here in the middle of it.
Yeah, it's good for him.
Living in the middle of the ocean really did stuff for him,
honestly.
just fucking hilarious.
I think the funny part is just the fact that he just lives
in the middle of the ocean now.
It's the ocean life for him.
Being rich as fuck probably helped a lot.
Oh yeah, like the guy who remember the guy talked about that
like used to use the son's blood to stay young and then he
ended up having incurable disease.
He tried so hard to live longer.
Okay, now I got another one of you.
Bro, I already got one.
I don't need another one.
Feed me the trash.
I crave the trash.
Tech, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is that karma for rich people?
I only heard about that in legends.
You mean rich people get to experience karma?
Oh my god.
say it ain't so
yeah so there was this for those who didn't know there was
it was a famous article about this like rich guy that would
like do like what's it called?
Blood infusion I don't know what it's called but they
swapped bloods with his with his son to stay young and then
there's blood transfusions right and then he ended up
getting a he ended up contracting an incredible disease,
where there's no cure, and he has to do treatment for the
rest of his life.
Yeah, blood trap, yeah.
After spending millions of dollars to stay young and
healthy.
To live, technically to try and live forever.
Yeah, you try to live forever and end up getting incurable
disease.
I don't remember what he got, though, to be fair.
Consequences for actions.
I know.
Wild.
Someone actually wrote a script for it.
I'm gonna get a cacha.
I'm streaming for six hours.
Trying to fucking try to find the last three cards.
I think I need three cards now.
Oh my god.
We're all upstairs.
The pile is gone.
Wait, I think I... What's that people?
sound.
Surely it's not a trash.
A garbage truck coming in with more trash.
Surely not.
I gotta grab all these dirty cards.
Clean.
Beep.
Alright.
Let's go clean the trash.
here.
Okay, come on, get back in here.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Alright, I
need to upgrade.
Oh, I still don't have enough for upgrades.
Draw your own card.
Oh, oh, that's cute.
Okay, I don't need this because I my flame collection.
According to all the Chinese dramas I watch on YouTube,
blood transfusions always needed to cure the sprain ankle
all the way to the heart issues.
Single super chat.
Thank you.
That's so true.
Sorry that, or is Lupus?
Another Iron Mouse.
I guess I don't need the flame cards.
I need was it water and death cards?
No.
I can finish the water.
I need death and angel card.
Damn it.
Come on.
I cleaned so many.
Oh my god.
Look, Matisha.
You're the goff queen.
But every time I got this card, I just see you.
Oh my god.
And jelly cat.
And always jelly cat.
I wish I can, like, use scroll wheel to turn these cards.
I have all of these guys already.
I wish I could skip cards if I have them already, so I can
just try and find the ones I don't have.
Oh, back to the grind!
Surely there's missing cards here, right?
right any more dirty cards any dirty cards in the pile for
me any cereal boxes come on wait wait i think i clear oh my
god jenny no jenny no she's gonna no she's gonna send more
That sounds like foreshadowing.
Alright.
It's okay.
Also, Jenny, why would the cards be ripped out?
Because, like, Jenny would have fucking...
It would be a dirty card.
Because she didn't fucking rip the cards out.
There we are.
Alright, another cat in a beer.
Oh my gosh, she'd be like, whoops, that's not the trash
pile.
That's yesterday trash.
Oh, hey, another cassette tape.
Alright, new music tab.
This is last one.
Ooh, retro party.
Oh, it's polka.
Okay.
Oh, it's over.
The trash pal.
Part one.
Oh, there's gonna be a new game.
Plus, I don't think we're ever gonna get the million
dollars.
card I don't think it even exists oh it's so clean it's so
clean
and oh my god that's a fucking heavy-ass trash bag all
right The garbage is gone.
They've cleaned up all the piles.
But I...
I...
Oh!
Maybe...
Easy breeze.
Okay.
Alright.
We're just missing the goff girls.
I got the full set.
Oh my gosh.
Don't worry.
People who are working guys.
Everyone, people who are at work, don't worry, I'll make
sure it's safe.
Oh,
you people at work right now, your hero is here, your
savior.
I'll make sure it's safe, God.
There we go.
You're a hero.
safe for work i'm literally missing these two cards i just
need two more
you're a hero keeping you safe for work don't worry your
boss won't see this
all right at least i'm close all right it's been a while
since I've been on the side.
Oh, I'm not gonna find the last one, am I?
Oh, this should be multiplayer.
Okay, chuck, chuck, chuck.
I just need two more.
I just need two more cards.
I just wanna know what's in the last two cards.
My collection isn't complete.
I need to complete my collection.
Oh, I ate stuff before the stream.
Don't worry, guys.
I do have some food in the fridge, too.
Okay.
Chug, chug, chug.
Oh, don't say that.
Okay, okay.
If we find one more goff card, I think the last...
The last goff card has to be the million dollar card.
It has to be.
There's no other way.
There's no other reason.
Uncle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Like, what could the last card be?
Let's put...
Okay, if I...
Please give me no...
Oh, wait.
This is the right one.
Whoops.
Oh my god, I have $10,000 in my savings.
I... I had $10,000 in my savings.
Okay, I need a...
I'm gonna buy speed.
I feel like speed's much more important at this point.
That gotta be faster.
It's like DPS damage per second.
You know?
It's damage per second.
Good.
Yeah, speed and bad.
But she engineed this and set the speed at times for it.
Okay.
Oh, if only I can use Skipper Skipper.
I must be able to upgrade.
Oh my god, of course it's all water.
No one cares about the water cards.
They're not meta right now.
Oh my god, it's a fucking course.
There's Matisha Adams.
Every time I need a golf card, it's here.
No wonder all our cards are ripped up.
I'm not surprised.
You know what?
I don't have enough yet.
Oh my god, I can level up again?
What the fuck do you mean I can level up again?
How bad is this card?
Yeah.
Oh, there's
no level-ups anymore.
Yeah, I only have one of that.
I swear to God, I have more genie cards.
Okay, two.
Please, I just want to know what are you?
She is the gop money, Nami.
Put respect to her.
name guys guess if we don't find the last two cards i'm
gonna give up this hobby i'm gonna sell my collection
no i'm gonna become a scalper right i've become i've i've
done it long enough to become the villains that's it we're
already into my villain arc
that's right
you were the chosen one
where are the dirty cards where are the cereal box I haven't
seen a single cereal box in so long
I buy too many?
They locked me out.
They actually open here.
Open up!
I need a drink!
99% of gamblers quit before they make it big.
okay there's one dirty card here oh my god nobody's throwing
i think they gave me that zero box high for one second and
then never again i need to pay the the dlc if i want it the
cereal box dlc to get that same hit again i took you had
enough you gotta go home and see your kids
Dirty cards.
We will finish this pile.
And I swear to God.
That we don't see at least one more gop card.
We're calling it.
It's over.
Okay.
I don't think I see any more dirty cards, though.
Honestly.
Oh, God.
Six hours of just cleaning.
Video games is an escapism.
It's just so...
keep reality where fantasies your dreams and fantasies can
be real
okay i don't think i see any more dirty cards though
but we'll just get the last pieces here
yeah why clean my room when i can clean my virtual garbage
dump
oh yeah i made a stripping asked me to send him alerts um
for a subathon i don't know if he put it in yet but i'll
show you guys what i sent him um let me show you guys almost
forgot about it
um let me see stripping you're in the files what did you do
that's that's one of my one of the ones i sent him if he
doesn't know what the alerts what was said in the alert
i don't know if he added it yet because i forgot to send it
to him before i went on business trip so I sent it to him
like today and his suppotan it was in the middle of his
suppotan when I sent it what did he do he doesn't know he
didn't he didn't um he doesn't know I just the other one
that I sent him Jim we're so fucked they know they know that
you It just cuts off right there.
You know what?
It's so over.
They would.
Guys, I don't think we're getting.
I don't think we're getting it in the last two cards.
I'm not about to get to Google's hockey.
Guys, none of these look like the dark cards.
None of this.
This is rigged.
Oh my god.
Skipper, skipper.
No amount of boobs would make me want to reconstruct this.
I swear.
I mean, I like this card, but I don't like seeing it 20
times in a row.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Is this the SSS?
Is this?
Wait.
Welcome to Diocardano.
Yes.
Finally...
Wait, wait, we're off.
You take a fire nap, but Doki's still alive on a one-off
game.
Love him out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Me was thinking, thank you.
I'm just, I'm the better gamer since I got the whole...
Oh, no!
No!
We one more card.
One more card.
We got it.
This is one last card.
Where are the bottles?
Guys, guys, we're so close.
We're so close.
It's literally the last card.
The last card in this collection.
Oh my god, I didn't mean to drink that.
We're almost there.
Oh my god.
I can actually see the finished live.
It's, we're almost there.
I said if we don't get it, We can't call it.
But then we got it.
We got it.
We got it, though.
We actually got it.
It's right there.
The card.
I can see it.
I can see the last card.
Okay.
I can feel it.
But the card guards by my side.
Big.
Diddy cop, girlfriend.
Let's go.
It's almost there.
The finish line.
Okay.
She's gonna...
She's gonna keep putting trash.
Trash man.
Zupapap.
Okay.
Oh, honey nut shirias.
Trash, trash, trash, trash, trash, trash.
What are things happened on the internet today, guys?
Anything exciting happened on the internet that I didn't
know about?
I have the glimmer of hope in my eyes.
Exciting things, not the sad stuff.
There's a reason why I didn't talk about the sad stuff.
Okay, we'll clean this.
Okay.
There's a reason why I didn't mention any of the sad stuff,
guys.
Oh, there she is.
Morticia Adams.
The Lego stuff?
I think they resolved it, though, didn't they?
I remember reading about that.
They resolved it a couple of days ago.
Or not, like, last week?
Where they're, like, they...
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
oh my god my collection it's complete oh my god it's alu
card oh my god i did it i complete the piece it's the piece
oh my god oh my god we did it we did it guys my beautiful
god i like that one card that is like ultra mint condition
like okay not who cares about this bitch but the first card
that i got as and the only card i got that was in um mint
condition is literally me, myself.
That's, it's the best looking card that I got.
It is cinema.
It was literally me.
It was destiny.
All right.
I'm done.
We did it.
Oh my god.
god we fucking did it oh we completed my collection oh yeah
we don't it's all right i'm a million dollars some says
she's still stuck there it's all right guys i think my card
was worth a million dollars in the end six hours six hours
of cleaning up trying to find cards and i'll do it again and
i'll do it all over again no i won't no i didn't if they add
more cards maybe if they round two if they add more cards
all right guys i think i told wait let me check Let me see
if I told all my, uh, if I told all my stories of Cap got to
say I'll talk more, but I felt like I, I said all my stories
while we were fucking digging through trash.
Let me double check, guys.
Um, I, oh yeah, I guess like I could have said this while we
were digging trash, but I saw the, I think the tour, the
Alcatraz tour, like I said, was, uh, still pretty, it was,
was really.
interesting um there was like i saw the isolate the isolate
like you know like walking around in the prison itself there
was like the isolation area the recreation oh it's so cold
it was such a cold place though because like it was an on a
fucking island i didn't realize there was a like like andy
and i we were like there's a bigger island next to alcatraz
island um called angel Island and it's a national state
park.
I was like, what the fuck is Angel Island?
And like, Andy's a goddamn local in San Francisco.
And even he was like, I don't even know.
I don't think I've heard about Angel Island before.
There's like, there's like a John ass island right next to
Alcatraz that like, apparently a lot of people don't know
about.
It's like, it's actually like a national it's a national
state park i like how it's an eight i like how it's right
next to alcatraz too right next to the maximum security
prison um like and it feels feels a little weird that the
national state park is next to a national maximum security
prison um oh really oh that's crazy i did not realize that
um but yeah it was really fun um uh uh capcon offices really
appreciate them inviting me and letting me have a little
tour around the office and oh i knew i forgot something the
leon stuff so um they gave me and uh do you guys know the
voice actor leon kennedy is an artist as well so um oh yeah
so for those know um i joked about what if i do a phone a
lifeline thing with um to the capcom team and they're like
oh you can do that it'll be funny and i was like oh what if
i call leon and originally it was supposed to be we call
leon but he was busy at that i think it was like flying the
gamescom at that time so we couldn't reach him and so i was
just like i'm gonna call mint because like you know she's a
she's the next person other than leon kennedy she's the next
person i would feel would know more most about the japan
stuff so why did i choose the fucking um japan history
question for a minute well i told her i was like i'm gonna
call you at 3 p.m and then and i didn't want to like make
her wait too long you know because she's like oh i can do it
but you need to tell me like what time you're gonna do this
and i was like okay it's gonna be at three and i gave her a
warning i'm like i'm gonna call you in 30 minutes and then
and then i and then Like, you know, I just didn't know it
was three o'clock and I was just like beep beep beep like at
any question at that point, you know, like I was like
whatever question I get at 3 p.m.
I'm just gonna yolo it like I'm just gonna call her because
we said three so I just want to know whatever question this
is the 3 p.m.
question.
So that's why we had Japanese I had to call her a Japanese
history.
And I was like, man, how dare you not know about ancient
Japan history?
Like, I'm just like, oh my God, I can't believe you know
nothing about it.
I, yeah,
but yeah, anyway, so, um, yeah, also her, I don't know why
her internet was, I think she was like walking around in New
York at that time, but, uh, yeah it's so you know can't
believe it what a larper doesn't know anything about ancient
japan history so yeah but anyway um it was really nice
because i asked andy of early like it was like a while ago
like when it was like post japan from capcom cup and i asked
him like uh because he was talking about the leon like how
he how the voice actor for leon is like such a cool guy and
how he dropped off some souvenirs to give to people and then
you know since I was like and he said he'll promise me he'll
like give me um his autograph uh that he dropped off for
people to give away to uh for other creators so I asked him
for and he gave me like uh it was a print it wasn't like uh
it was one of the prints that he made of his own artwork
that he signed so I have the an art so basically I have an
autograph from the voice actor of Leon Kennedy it'll be cool
to meet him one day But I think it was really cool to have,
you know, a signed artwork that he drew.
Oh, let me say I can get it.
Oh, let me grab it real quick.
It's in my suitcase that I did not unpack as always.
Right there.
Whoa.
All right, let me take a picture of it.
And yeah, he drew.
I did not realize he was an artist, too.
It's really beautiful.
He's like a black and white sketch.
it is and it's beautiful
can't crop this
all right i'm sending this to myself oh yeah i was gonna
show you guys the pokemon cards thing too i didn't realize i
forgot about that okay all right
let me save this
Okay, and then, let's see, I'm going to check if there's no
reflection.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
So, it looks like this.
Oh, that's a big picture.
So, yeah, you can see the, so it's a signed print top left.
He signed that.
So, like, this is Leon Kennan's, like, the voice actor Leon
Kennan's artwork that he drew.
But it's a print.
It's not, like, the original artwork that he, you know,
what's it called?
The original drawing?
Yeah, it's not the original drawing, but it's a print of it.
So I thought it was really cool.
And there's his autograph on the top left.
Yeah, and his artwork.
He's an artist.
Also, here's the Pokemon cards I was talking about.
Like, it's the first time I've, like, I didn't realize how,
like, Like, seeing that in real life was crazy.
Like, holy shit, it's just all gone.
There's just nothing there.
Yeah, I was just like, holy shit.
I've never seen that in person before.
I've seen, like, photos and stuff of, like, videos of, like,
scalpers, like, trying to get Pokemon cards.
But I've never seen, like, this in person.
like it's not as bad in Canada but we also have all our
stuff locked up in like glass cases and you have to ask the
yeah like it's not just out there it's just in Canada you
have to actually ask the um you have to ask like the um the
staff to what's the word like the people who work um at the
at the store the attendance attendance to like unlock it for
you we don't even have the vending machines too i don't
think so yeah never i don't really see the vending machines
at all in canada uh yeah the employees you had to ask the
employees to unlock the glass cases to grab any of the
pokemon cards in canada so like it's i thought it was wild
seeing this such an empty fucking so empty.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call here.
I didn't think I would be playing six hours of just digging
through trash, but we're back, baby.
Don't need to travel until, I guess, like, next month.
I'll be traveling again.
End of next month.
Not, don't worry.
So we still have a couple of weeks of more of streaming
before I go away again.
Another business trip uh can't say what it is yet uh but um
but it's gonna be fun it's gonna be exciting it's gonna be
fun um for the next one and I have like three more business
trips uh left for this year and I should be good for 2026
like yeah um but it won't be I think it'll be gone for like
two days I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure I'm only for the
next one it's just two to three days um Anyway, guys, thank
you for hanging out with me.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up,
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
Make sure to check out the merch, guys.
It's the last day, so make sure you grab your Doki merch
before it's too late, everybody.
Let's make sure to grab the...
Let me link it.
Spam the link.
I'm my own spammer.
That's right.
I can spam the link because...
Because I'm the streamer.
Oh yeah, I need to pin the new schedule too.
Thanks for reminding me.
I need to do the schedule stuff too.
But yes!
Check out the merch before it's too late ends today.
And then I guess the only time you can get the merch is get
that specific merch is if you catch it at the conventions
and stuff during the convention run.
But I want to guarantee those merch you better pre-order it.
you know you want to you know you want to grab the little
boxers the little tomato boxers i mean but uh this is the
best part honestly you know you want it there's his face
welcoming you and saying goodbye so make sure to grab them
before it's too late hey guys i'll see you guys later
everybody Bye guys.
Bye.